This is Jocko podcast number 70 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo,
good evening.
Now it's going to start off tonight with a warning that tonight's episode is
going to contain things that are not appropriate for children.
Then as I,
as I put together the notes,
I realized that maybe the opposite is true
and that maybe this is an important episode that children do need to listen to,
but I would say listen to it alone by yourself first without your children and
then decide if and when they are ready to listen to this.
And unfortunately I will tell you that I think the time is likely sooner than
you think and it is most definitely sooner than it should be.
Now,
normally
I am talking about war
and
in that light I have covered some of the most heinous
and horrible things that have happened in the world.
Evil things,
evil people,
and the things that I'm talking about
are things that happen on a large scale and in a war.
Battles between nations and armies of versus armies and men
against men.
And
in those situations on that global stage
of war,
as I always say,
we see
the best of human nature
and we often see the worst,
but sometimes the worst of human behavior,
the most evil of human behavior does not occur on the battlefield.
And it is not driven by war.
It's not brought on by the madness of combat.
It's not the result of men trying to kill other men.
Sometimes the most evil side of human beings
sneaks around in the dark,
lurking,
waiting,
preying on the weak.
Yeah,
scared
and the defenseless,
preying on
children.
And often it isn't some arc type of evil.
Okay?
Like the picture you have in your head of some sneering Predator with a sadistic
look.
It can often be
a trusted neighbor
from our frame we friend
or even a relative.
And to talk through some of this with me tonight,
I'm honored to have a special guest on an amazing person
that I admire
for her toughness and courage,
incredibly strong woman,
loving mother,
and extremely hard working in a highly productive farmer.
And last,
but certainly not least,
an incredible wife to one of my very close friends who has done multiple combat
tours overseas,
leaving this wonderful woman back on the home front to handle the business at
home.
And her name is Iris.
And my first solid memory of Iris,
and I had met her before this,
but you know,
I didn't really think too much about it,
but I was driving out to see her husband out on a farm out on their farm that
they live on.
And I,
I pulled up my vehicle,
my minivan,
I'm quite sure,
and I'm looking across the spance of land and out there in the field,
fully nine months pregnant,
guiding a horse drawn plow.
Right.
I'm talking,
it looks like it's 1729 out there,
horse-drawn plow in the field in the summertime and in the valley in the,
in the inland of southern California.
So it's hot and dusty and she sees me and she like ties off the horse and then
she comes walking over to me and she's wearing the actual spurs like you see in
a western movie that Jingle Jangle.
No kidding.
And she's a small frame,
a woman,
you know,
and she took off,
she had a pair of leather gloves on that looked like they were passed down from
the Marlboro man.
It just all worked and she took one of those off and it gave me a handshake and
her,
her skin was basically as tough as the leather gloves she was wearing and she,
you know,
said Hey,
and pointed me towards her house where I'd find her husband who was in there
like watching TV or something in the air condition.
And then she turned around and walked back and headed back out to field again.
She was nine months straight up,
nine months pregnant and I thought to myself,
damn
breath,
what a,
what an awesome woman.
So
okay,
years later,
I would say maybe five,
four or five years later,
I was
extremely moved and angered and disturbed and thankful and odd all at the same
time when she posted an article online about something she had experienced as a
child.
And
here is an excerpt of what she wrote.
I was only five years old.
The first time it happened
I wasn't feeling well,
so while everyone else went down the hill to cut firewood,
I stayed back at the cabin in bed.
I remember him coming back,
coming through the door and telling me he needed to get a chainsaw file.
He then came over to the bed,
told me to lay still and pulled my pants down.
I was a shy child,
had would never ever have questioned and adult at that age.
He inserted his fingers into my vagina and I remember it hurting and I was just
petrified.
I had no idea what to do.
You said things to me like,
doesn't that feel good and you like this right?
I was unable to say anything or I don't know.
I may have even mumbled agreement with him because that's what I thought I was
supposed to do.
Yeah.
I just remember that it hurt and I was scared and I was confused.
The sound of my parents' truck pulling up the driveway stopped him and he
carefully pulled my pants back up and went over to the sink and washed his hands
as if washing away the evidence.
He then pulled me close and told me that this was a secret just between us.
Okay.
It was so cliche.
It amazes me now that that's what he said and
how well it worked.
Okay.
Now
I
have faced fear,
top faced horror.
I've faced evil,
but I faced it as a full grown man
who spent pretty much my entire life being trained to fight and to kill and
prepared to die.
Yeah.
And furthermore,
when I was in those situations,
not only was I a full grown man,
I was with my brothers in arms to my left and to my right,
okay?
But to face this kind of evil as a child,
as a little girl,
and I have three daughters
scared,
defenseless,
and Oh alone,
this is almost impossible for me to comprehend.
And I know that I can learn a lot
from the type of person that can survive this kind of abuse.
I know we can all learn a lot,
especially from a person with the strength to confront this evil and overcome it
and then put together an amazing
and beautiful life with an amazing and beautiful family.
We can all learn from this.
And with that mind,
iris,
welcome to the show.
Hey,
thank you so much for coming on.
Wow.
Thank you,
Jocko.
Yes.
Uh,
it's really an honor to be here
and like all of our guests now
you have to tell us about the beginning where you came from,
what was going on in your life and your,
your life is very internet.
I remember when your husband first met you and he was kind of telling me about
this girl he had met and I was sick.
You know,
when you hear your story,
you just think,
damn,
that's awesome.
And so tell us a little bit about that,
about your childhood.
You had a lot of very cool experiences in your,
in your childhood and grew up in a,
in a almost completely unique way that I don't think I've ever met anyone else.
I grew up like you did.
Yeah.
I,
um,
I never realized it was really unique until I wasn't an adult.
Got Out in the world a little bit more and realize that most people,
um,
anywhere near my age did not grow up the way that I did.
So we lived in,
um,
the mountains in northern California.
My Dad was,
uh,
initially a minor,
a gold miner,
and he would go into old mine shafts and bring out,
or that they would crush in a,
in a small mill and then refine the gold down into bars that they would sell.
And eventually he became a timber faller and a lager.
Um,
back in 1987,
I was seven years old.
There's a huge forest fire that burned through northern California.
And I remember it vividly because one night there was just this wall of fire
rolling down on our house.
And Luckily our house was spared,
but a lot of our neighbors lost their homes.
And after that,
a lot of logging came into the area because there was so much
burned.
But I remember,
so a lot of people have parents that might be working in mines.
They might have parents that are working as you know,
loggers or lumberjacks,
but they still might have things in their house like power and heat and
electricity.
So you guys were like off the grid,
right?
Yeah,
that the whole area.
So,
so this place is probably one of the most rural places in this country still,
unless maybe you get up into Alaska.
Um,
it's in northern California,
in the mountains.
There's this gorgeous river valley there and it still doesn't have electricity.
Um,
the people that live there still just use some solar now or generators,
but no one had that back when I was a kid.
So yeah,
we grew up with,
um,
no power,
no telephones,
no television.
We used the old school,
um,
kerosene lanterns with the little thin glass globes and you would carry those
from room to room if you needed light.
We would take them to bed with us at night and read by kerosene lantern.
And we had a wood cook stove that we cooked on,
um,
just to get hot water.
Our Wood Cook Stove had coils that ran through it that the water would run
through and warm it.
So you would have to start a fire in the stove to have any hot water to warm it.
So yeah,
it was,
it was interesting.
I,
I take power and things like that for granted now,
but back then it was just normal.
Yeah.
That was going to say it becomes normal for kids.
I know that for instance,
when my kids were little,
they just thought that everyone did.
You did Jitsu cause we did Jujitsu.
Oh yeah.
Do you know,
doesn't everyone do dude,
you did sue all the time,
but just know no power and that's Kinda there.
Yeah.
It's hard for people to even imagine that nowadays when you're a kid and you
don't have an iPad to entertain you,
you don't have a TV to entertain you.
The creativity has to be there.
Right.
It has to develop because what did you do for fun?
Well,
we had rocks.
I know what we're seeing.
When I was a kid,
I,
when I was a kid,
it was like everything,
every stick you could find turned it into a machine gun and every rock you found
turned into a grenade and that's where we did.
Did you even,
how would you even know what a grenade was or,
you know,
how would you know what a doll was?
Yeah,
we had,
we had a few toys,
but you know,
I see the toys that kids have now and it definitely isn't it different is very
different.
Uh,
we had a few,
a few old toys,
but mostly we just lived outside.
We just outside was our,
that was our playground or toys.
And then where were you guys getting food from?
We always had a big garden.
My mom,
um,
grew,
it grew.
He grew a huge garden and canned and froze or Weldon freeze.
We didn't have electricity for a freezer,
but cad and dried food and we had our own milk cows.
Um,
we raised pigs,
which that,
that was kind of interesting to my,
we had a lot of pigs.
My sister and I used to sleep outside in this,
um,
in the summers when the weather was nice,
there was this old stone root cellar with like a loft that had open ends and we
would sleep up there whenever the weather was a little bit iffy and it was right
over top of the pig pen.
So we essentially grew up in a barn.
Um,
we would wake up in the middle of night with pigs squealing and turn our
flashlights on and shine the lights down there and watch like litters of piglets
being born.
And these weren't even normal pigs.
They were like wild boars that we'd caught and bread.
And so they were all hairy and long snouts and they weren't like your fat pink
pigs that you get that most people race.
And did you,
was there any kind of school up there?
There was a tiny little school that we went to when I lived there.
It was sort of the height of the population.
There's less people there now,
but there was the mining and the logging had brought in a few more people.
And so the school that I went to had about 25 kids from k through eight.
So there's maybe a couple of kids per grade and we were all in the same.
It was,
there was like two rooms,
the big kids' room and the little kids room.
And we were so close because there were just a few of us and we were s every,
all of the kids that I grew up with had very similar upbringing to the way I
did.
So there are at least 25 other kids out there in the world who grew up exactly
the same as I did,
but we were this pack of just feral children really,
um,
that just lived in the woods and swam in the river and,
and,
um,
did everything.
And I have wonderful memories of that,
which offset a lot of the not so pleasant things that happened in that same
time.
Did you,
uh,
what about books?
Did you guys have a ton of books?
Did you read,
was that sort of your one escape from the reality that was around you?
Yeah,
we didn't have television.
And in the summers we were mostly outside and the river,
um,
and the woods,
we would go down to the river in the evening and watch the bears catch salmon
and
sounds like a pretty normal after that five year old.
But in the winter when it was cold and rainy,
we read a ton and I've got the best big sister in the world.
She's a couple years older than me and she
was reading these just ridiculously age inappropriate books.
I remember her reading these huge novels when she was like 10 years old because
we didn't have any money.
And it wasn't like our parents went out and bought us the,
the newest children's books or anything to read.
We just read whatever happened to be laying around.
And,
um,
oftentimes that was not what you would typically give a 10 year old to read.
But so she would,
she,
she started reading to herself and then she would read to me before I was,
eh,
you know,
and eventually I became an very avid reader too.
Um,
but yeah,
that was,
that was a big part of her life.
In fact.
Um,
Cormac McCarthy is also one of my very favorite authors,
if not my favorite author.
I think I,
I read,
um,
all the pretty horses in the crossing when I was like 15,
I had red blood meridian by the time I was 16.
I've read them all numerous times,
but I remember,
uh,
this wonderful old neighbor lady that lived down the road from us gave me this
box of a big cardboard box full of old Louis L'amour and Zane grey novels,
which for anyone who's not familiar with those,
they're,
they're westerns.
They're all westerns.
And that was,
you know,
the way you talk about being a kid and sort of wanting to be a soldier,
wanting to be in the military so bad.
And that was like,
you are focused on that and that's all you are going to do.
That was me.
But with horses,
that was the only thing I cared about.
And so I,
I just gobbled up all of these old westerns and lived in that world of imagining
myself being like a cowboy riding across the plains with my bedroll and,
but I didn't have a horse.
So,
um,
you know,
I lived in the woods as much as I could.
I,
we,
we foraged,
we found,
um,
we hunted for wild mushrooms all the time,
which is still one of my very favorite things to do.
Um,
and I used to read mushroom and plant field guides,
like other kids might read,
you know,
fantasy novels or something.
So it's,
uh,
it's a definitely unique and a lot of really,
I mean,
that's just an unbelievable experience.
And it sounds like you,
you definitely a lot of positivity,
you know,
there's so much positivity to that,
the way you grew up.
It was a very idyllic childhood.
I would say that I have a lot of darkness in that same time,
but I wouldn't trade the way that I grew up for anything.
Dang.
So let me talk a little bit about that.
That
and I kinda talked about in that,
in that opening of of how it started and and the first time it happened to you,
this,
this abuse that you suffered.
Now I'm going to go back to this article that you wrote
and here we go
again.
This is,
this is the,
this is from a five year old.
I was confused mostly.
I don't think it ever crossed my mind to tell my parents.
I just knew that I had been instructed not to tell anyone,
so that's what I did.
I really didn't understand what he had done or why,
but I definitely knew that what had been done was wrong and it might be
something that I would be punished for.
From that moment on my life became one big game of cat and mouse.
I tried to avoid him and he pursued me and took every opportunity to get his
hands on me.
He had plenty of opportunities because he was a beloved and trusted family
friend.
Even right in front of my parents and other people.
He would regularly slap my butt and pull me onto his lap.
I would always scorm away as quickly as I could.
I remember being left home with him.
I remember throwing fits and begging to go along with my mom and my sister,
my mom,
just thinking I was acting out and being a brat and would tell me to stay with
him until they got back.
The fact that no one realized what was happening by simply observing the
situation still be wielders me.
So this guy,
like you said here,
okay,
this guy had full access to your house,
full trust of your parents.
Why is it that you think or expand,
you kind of talk about it a little bit,
but what is it that that makes a kid hold that information in when something bad
is happening like this?
So I think it started happening with me when I was so young that I just,
I didn't understand it.
I did not understand what was even going on.
No one had ever told me that something like that might happen.
And I was told not to say anything by an adult.
And I didn't.
And I think I definitely had a feeling that I knew something was wrong and that
this was not what should be happening,
but I was a lot of,
it was probably just my personality type.
I was a shy,
quiet kid and
I wasn't inclined to express my emotions that much anyways.
Um,
and I,
you know,
I think people who do this sort of thing,
they look for a specific type of kid.
They're not stupid.
They know how to single out just the right kid.
And that was me in,
in the time and
I just had,
I had a lack of understanding of what was even going on.
Um,
I didn't really know that it was definitely something that I should tell other
adults.
And I'm thinking that in your,
in your situation,
in your upbringing,
you're seeing,
you're seeing nature,
right?
You're understanding that pigs are having babies.
I mean,
you're seeing this kind of thing take place,
but it wasn't something that your family talked about,
the birds and the bees or anything like that just didn't come up.
Yeah,
not really.
And definitely not in.
I think that it's hard for people to believe that their best friend or close
family members would ever harm their children.
And so I don't,
I suspect that my parents felt like they kept a pretty good eye on me and that I
was fine because they didn't look where they needed to look.
I think that's,
and I'm sure echo has some kind of bias,
psychological bias for this,
but you know,
anytime you're in a situation where there's something that you simply could
never imagine,
it couldn't believe it,
and if that's,
if that's,
if something that you could never imagine and couldn't believe happening and
you're not being told about it,
what would plant that in your mind do you know,
to make you think that it's going on from your parents perspective?
You know,
it's like,
it's like me looking at one of my close friends,
I would never have that thought.
And so where would it come from?
Well,
kind of see how it would not probably think that your kid would let you know if
there was a problem.
Right?
You would be like,
well,
I would be able to tell if something was wrong because my kid would let me know
somehow and that's not necessarily the case.
I'm going to go back as you continue this back to your writing here.
Yeah.
We moved into our own house
and I would have moments of peace,
but he was always around,
always visiting and even parked a trailer on our property to live in for periods
of time.
He stalked me like I was his prey.
Okay.
I never ever felt safe from him.
He would watch me constantly.
I would look up from playing with toys and see him standing in the doorway of my
bedroom staring at me.
I would wake up to him watching me
when I would have friends over,
I would suddenly jump up and announced that we needed to go outside and play
right now
because I would notice him watching us through a doorway or a window.
Okay.
Again,
I can't even,
I can't even imagine what that had to feel like for a five year old,
a six year old,
a seven year old.
And again,
I picture my own children and they're pure in the sense that they live in,
thankfully,
and I can't,
I can't,
I mean this is like a horror movie.
You know,
you're a kid and you're looking up and,
and you're playing with your toys and your reading your book or whatever,
and you look up and you see this Predator,
you know,
just,
just stalking you all the time and,
and the discomfort that you had to just feel constantly
and,
and no way to escape it.
Do you think there's,
was there anything else that you,
that you can think of that you tried to do or tried to send them a signal or was
it just,
or you just so sort of envelops by the situation that you didn't,
you know,
just like I was talking about maybe your parents couldn't imagine what would be
happening.
Is it,
was it like you just couldn't imagine this not happening?
Yeah,
pretty much.
I think because it started when I was so young,
it just was part of my life and it was so consistent.
It wasn't like something that happened and then didn't happen for,
it was just like a daily part of my life.
And so I don't think I really ever tried to signal.
I remember one time there was a couple girls,
some friends of my parents came and visited and they had a couple of girls a
little bit older than me.
They came.
And I remember the one girl who was probably 12 at the time telling me they
spent the night,
they slept outside.
And she told me that,
um,
when she woke up in the morning,
this,
my abuser had
like crawled up on to her bed and started touching her leg and she like jumped
up and told them no and ran away.
And she also didn't go a grown up.
She came and told me that this had happened.
And I remember telling her what happened to me.
And that's the only time as a child that I ever told anyone.
And I remember us sitting there kind of discussing this.
I was probably eight maybe at the time.
And we're like,
wow,
that's,
yeah,
I don't know why he does this.
That's,
that's weird.
I am,
I don't know.
You know?
And we just kind of disgusted and then never told anyone.
Even though she was even older and hadn't grown up with it.
And I don't know if later on she told someone,
but at the time she definitely didn't go tell her parents or my parents or
anyone,
which reaffirms the fact that your kids aren't necessarily going to tell you.
Hmm,
I know.
I know with my kids,
you know,
if they do something that they think is going to get him in trouble,
especially in that five,
six year year old,
seven year old,
they're not going to tell you.
They don't fall into your,
that information if they think it's something that they did wrong or think so.
So that's another little trap.
Okay.
That occurs
back to your writing here.
He was old and was missing all of his teeth.
He wore dentures sometimes and sometimes he didn't.
I remember him pinning me up against the walls and counters and kissing me with
his soft toothless mouth and fingering me with his dirty hands.
I wanted to vomit.
I would never tell him know though.
Never tell him to get away from me.
Never acknowledged that he was doing anything to me.
I would just slip away from him.
As soon as an opportunity presented itself and mumbled that I was going outside
to play or down to the rock piles,
my secret labyrinth of tangled blackberry brambles and boulders,
you'd follow me to the top of the trail saying things like,
come back.
You like what I'm doing?
Or,
I don't think your mom wants you to go down there while she's gone.
But he never followed me down into the rock piles.
It was my safe zone.
It was the place I could cry with no one seeing me.
I remember someone accusing him of molesting another little girl.
I heard my parents talking about it and then my dad pulling me aside and asking
me if Mike had ever touched me.
I was caught off guard and totally unprepared to deal with what saying yes would
mean
so I said no,
as soon as it was out of my mouth,
I wanted so badly to change my answer,
but no one ever asked me again.
I'm convinced that if I had had a little time to think and had been asked again,
I would have spilled it all.
Remember that it's important.
But at the time I said No.
And the woman who made the accusation was discredited as being crazy or a drug
addict and having ulterior motives.
And that was that.
Okay.
So there is a clear example and I could,
I could see now going from the perspective of a parent who is all uncomfortable
to go up and ask this question in the first place.
You know,
it was probably the weakest form of questioning too,
you know,
like,
has Mike ever made you feel weird and you,
you know,
uh,
no.
Okay.
But he's good now.
Dad's like,
okay,
see,
I told you this is no issue.
She's a liar.
She's a drug addict
and they want that answer.
They want to hear no.
Yeah.
Any parent wants to hear?
No.
When they asked that.
Okay.
It and,
and yet you got to ask again.
You got to put it probably in multiple different ways of asking the question,
not just as he make you on,
keep,
feel comfortable.
Does he touch you?
Do you got to ask that in so many different ways to get to open up the mind to
the kid,
you know,
obviously without asking leading questions.
Right.
You know,
that's gonna that's gonna make put somebody,
you know,
in another weird situation.
Yeah.
How do you ask your own kids?
So,
okay.
I think that
you have to,
you have to talk about it casually,
hopefully before something happens.
Um,
make them aware of the fact that this does happen.
And
yeah,
people think that they're protecting their kids by not telling them that
horrible stuff happens.
They,
they feel like they're protecting them by shielding them from this.
And meanwhile their kids are being molested and don't know how to tell anyone
because no one's talked to them about it.
Yeah.
And so you can start talking to them when they're really young.
Use simple terms and express that sometimes people do bad things and there's
something I tell my kids that there's something broken in some people's brains
that makes them do something that normal people don't do,
but that they're out there.
And when you,
I think when you question a kid about this,
you have to ask it once
and then give the top the,
give the kid time to think about it and then bring it up casually again a couple
days later.
Hey you remember that thing we talked about the other day?
I was thinking about it some more.
Um,
do you have,
you know,
is there anything else you want to talk to me about with that and do that a few
times,
especially if you have any,
if you suspect anything for sure,
but even if you don't bring it up once,
bring it up again a couple of days later.
Bring it up again a couple days later.
Give their little brains time to process what my and then make sure to tell them
that if anything happened,
even if they're not telling me anything,
did
they are not going to be in trouble if they feel like they want to tell me
something now some kids are just vocal and we'll talk fine,
but other kids won't.
And that's the kind of kid that you have to eat,
get out of.
If you think about this,
you could actually develop a pattern with your kids where they're not talking
about molestation,
but if when they tell you something,
you punish them because they told you the truth.
Yeah,
because they took a cookie drop the cookie jar,
spilled milk and they could have kept it a secret,
but they told you and now you punish them.
You're,
you're doing the same thing.
You're setting them up for to keep secrets and keep things in
[inaudible] I always tell my kids that they'll get in more trouble for telling
me a lie then for whatever they do
did in the first place.
My,
uh,
my kids absolutely know that.
And,
and that's the same with [inaudible].
Nevermind kids when I was in the teams.
That's the standard.
You tell me what happened.
The don't lie to me.
What happened if you tell me something,
you did something wrong.
There was an incident,
something bad happened,
we'll handle it.
But one thing we can't do is if we try and cover something up and we get caught
now,
now there's going to be hell to pay.
So yeah,
that's a,
another thing that I do with my kids is I got it.
There's some great books out there about talking to your kids about abuse and
stuff and um,
there's one that I read to him sometimes and it's not,
those books aren't meant to just read once and never pick up again.
They are a perfect opportunity to bring it up casually in conversation.
There's a,
it's called,
I said no and it's written by Zach and Kimberly King and Zach is a little boy
and his mom,
Kimberly King,
and they wrote this book together and it's really great.
It taught,
it talks about people as being like red flag people and those people can be the
sort of people who just give you a strange feeling.
They,
they on subtle you,
they make you feel a little bit odd and it doesn't necessarily mean that they've
done anything wrong to you,
but you should be able to pick out those red flag people and then talk to an
adult about what is making them uncomfortable.
No,
no.
Is that,
is that because the,
this red flag person did something that,
that gave them a regular black person.
And I told my kids,
especially now that my daughters are older,
you know,
one of my daughters was going on a trip somewhere and I,
and I was giving her the talk,
you know,
listen,
you need to watch out.
And my daughter said something to me like,
Dad,
I'm not going to be,
do you know,
going and hanging around with some Weirdo.
And I stopped her right in her tracks and I said,
it's not the Weirdo,
the guy that looks weird.
It's not the guy that looks like a Predator that you need to watch out for.
The guy that you need to watch out for is the guy that seems like a nice guy.
He's a guy that just,
you know,
helped you with your luggage,
is the guy,
uh,
not all of them.
Yeah.
But you need to watch out for that.
And if you look at some of those serial killers,
you know,
uh,
I think it was,
I think it was Ted Bundy,
but he had the whole thing where he had his arm in a cast and he would ask
someone to help him.
You'd ask her a woman to help,
hey,
I need to get my groceries in the car or whatever.
And they see this kind of,
and if you ever saw a picture of me,
it looks like a nerd and he has his arm in a cast and he's got a collared shirt
on,
he looks like a white collar guy and he's got a car and,
and you know,
next thing you know,
as soon as they don't help with the groceries,
boom,
the arms out of the cast.
And he's,
he's abducting them.
And so,
so what do,
how do they identify like the red flag people more about
your,
your gut intuition.
If there's something that just makes you feel a little bit weird if they say
something,
you know,
it's listening.
It's about listening to that internal voice that might be telling you
something's a little weird,
but he's a really nice guy,
you know,
he's,
and,
and learning how to identify that and listen to it.
Um,
because yeah,
that's like I said,
pedophile sexual predators,
they're not stupid people.
Most of them aren't stupid people.
They're very calculating and they look for the right opportunities.
So you've,
yeah,
you've got to teach your kid specifically that.
Yeah.
It seems like you need to teach your kids specifically the,
the,
I said no part,
right?
Because even you as a kid,
you don't know how to say no.
You don't know how to scream.
You don't know how to tell someone to stop and,
and also how to identify what you know.
Kids don't know where the line is.
If you don't teach them what's right and what's wrong in terms of physical
contact with them,
then how,
how are they going to know?
How are they going to know?
Exactly.
That's a good point.
Now you,
you don't want to scold the kid for making a mistake and you know how you hold
lying is in higher regard as far as violations go.
Where if this environment is kind of created that what you say doesn't mean that
much.
So be careful with what you said,
you know,
but if the environment is,
hey,
you can come to me with anything and you demonstrate that,
don't just say like once a month,
say,
hey,
you can come to me with anything next day.
They come to you with something.
You're like,
Hey,
I'm busy.
Or Hey,
grown ups are talking,
you know,
so if you actually provide that environment consistently,
they'll come to you with anything.
Anything that's off.
They'll be like,
yeah,
hey mom,
what's this?
Hey,
there's a rabbit in the backyard,
you know,
so even something that small,
so some Weirdo or some red flag person comes and they're doing something strange
out of the ordinary,
they're going to come to you
way more likely,
you know?
Yeah.
You know,
we talk about inoculation when it comes to training for combat and you know,
you,
you inoculate yourself distress and,
and one of the things I talk about like with self defense for especially for
women is if you train Jujitsu,
you get inoculated to the fact that someone's going to be grabbing you,
touching you,
grinding on you and it's,
and so you're over that,
you're over that.
But it seems like this is the same situation you do with kids where you or knock
you late them to the uncomfortable conversations.
So they're okay talking about stuff that,
let's face it,
you know,
there's,
your kid is not going to be comfortable talking about some things unless you
inoculate them and you get them used to it and they understand what's right and
what's wrong.
I think it's correct what you said.
It's the parents are typically the ones going to be more uncomfortable.
Like the key,
you'd be surprised with kids.
They'll just talk about,
yeah,
like weird.
Unless you made it uncomfortable for them.
Yeah.
We'll talk about some weird stuff,
especially five,
six.
But if the parents,
hey,
and you know in your scenario where they'll ask you something,
you give the answer,
they say,
good,
that's the answer I want.
Let's don't talk anymore.
Because they're uncomfortable
and it's all on the parent to initiate these conversations.
It's not on the little kids to come to you and tell you something big has
happened.
It's on you as a parent to initiate these conversations.
Yeah.
My daughter is,
um,
she's,
she's shy and she doesn't express her emotions very well.
She's not the kind of kid who comes and just tells you stuff and I don't,
I don't want this to sound like I'm beating this stuff into my kids' heads every
day and terrorizing them with the thought of scary things that might happen to
them because I'm not,
you know,
I talk it casually enough.
I think that it gets through to them,
but she had,
she's in kindergarten and she had a little issue and she told me that a boy has
been coming up to her on the playground and she,
I always use correct terminology because that's another thing I want.
I feel like kids should be comfortable talking about their bodies and she told
me,
and it was hard for her to tell me she didn't want to tell me and I could
totally see it because of her personality.
She came up and she's,
she told me that a little boy was coming up every day on the playground and like
poking her in the vagina and then asking her to do the same to him and she's,
I think she's five.
She told me that and I was like,
okay,
what I'm doing is working,
because knowing her personality,
she didn't want to tell me that,
but she did.
And so as the NFL,
that was also the perfect experience to sort of teach like,
okay,
cool.
Not a big deal.
He's five years old,
you know,
they little kids do that and they don't know what they're doing.
But let's go talk to your teacher and make sure,
you know.
And I immediately took action and showed her that I wasn't gonna let anything
happen to her if she was uncomfortable with it,
without blowing it out of proportion.
I was going to say,
cause a lot of times the what kids are embarrassed about from aged,
whatever it is,
they don't want to tell you,
cause you know my,
my 17 year old will do that as well.
My seven year old Dad Dad told,
you know,
so I think that's another thing is how do you make sure that they realize that
you're going to be,
you know,
without blowing it out of proportion,
which,
which I agree with you,
you know,
it's a five year old kid.
It's a five year old boy.
They're doing,
like you said,
they're talking about stupid stuff that they don't understand and they're doing
things that they don't understand yet.
That's like,
okay but,
but let's now teach them,
let's let them learn at that.
And that gave me a lot of confidence that if something,
because I,
because she dealt with that in a great way,
you have something bigger where to happen.
I now feel like she would be much more inclined to come to me.
But what you're saying about not wanting to make a scene,
I think as I got older and and understood what was happening to me a lot more
than I did when I was little.
Yeah,
I didn't want to make a scene.
This is somebody who was my parents' best friend,
was deeply involved in our life,
had been with us for ever and imagine what
taling would look like.
And that wasn't something that I was prepared to handle even when I was a
teenager and I knew exactly what was going on and I knew exactly how wrong it
was.
The scene that would ensue if I said something was not something that I was
willing to deal with,
that's even hard for to do
any kind of like confrontation that's going to cause these big ripples.
It's like,
man,
I got to weigh all this out now.
You know,
like,
can I strengthen myself up versus,
you know,
create this big scene.
I'd rather deal with strengthening myself up in DC.
You have no idea in your mind,
you probably made it even a bigger crazy.
See you were probably thinking that they were going to have to make a choice
between you and this guy.
You know,
maybe in your mind that's your best friend.
now you've got to convince people,
it just becomes easier to just not say anything.
You don't know if they're going to believe you.
You don't know if he's going to go to jail.
You,
you just don't know what the consequences are going to be.
And it's much easier to just be like,
all right,
I've dealt with this.
I can keep dealing with this.
I'm not gonna cause any ripples.
So as you go along,
to go back to your writing here,
okay.
As I grew older,
I got better and better at avoiding him.
His hounding of me did not decrease,
but I rarely let him get his hands on me.
I was incapable of just telling him to get away from me.
If he got me cornered,
I'm not sure how to explain what this is like.
This constant pursuit and hounding that you are unable to avoid when you are a
child.
When I was 12 years old,
we moved,
it was over seven years of stress and fear and pain finally replaced with an
empty discomfort.
A weight was lifted from my shoulders.
I got a horse and felt more freedom than I ever had
and then he followed
okay.
He bought a piece of property just up the hill from us and that was the
beginning of dealing with him.
As a teenager,
I never let him touch me again.
I tolerated as crude comments and ate dinner next to him at the dinner table.
I laughed at his jokes and I do to flee.
Rode my horse up the hill to check on him every couple of days.
At the insistence of my parents,
he would always come out of his trailer and lay a hand on my thigh,
invite me to tie up and come inside.
I still couldn't look them in the,
I still couldn't tell him to fuck off.
Instead,
I would just change the subject and ride off with a hollow pit in my stomach.
So you move away and then he follows you there.
Okay.
You know,
you
talk about how hard it is to explain this,
this hounding that you got and you're trapped.
You can't,
you don't feel like you can say anything to your family.
You can't get away from him.
And this has just gotta be,
I mean,
you,
you see a hollow pit in your stomach
and this has just got to be eating at you.
Yeah.
And you find finally some comfort in horses,
which was already your dream.
And now you finally get,
you finally get your first horse.
Yeah.
That was,
um,
the best thing that ever happened to me up until that point.
At least maybe ever.
Um,
there was a neighbor lady that lived close to us who had this horse that she
didn't have time for and she let me bring it home and start riding it.
And I didn't,
my family never had horses.
We knew nothing about horses other than my just insane desire to have one.
And so I just started riding it and this horse was half broke at best and I
would fall off constantly.
I just would smack my head on the ice and get back on and fall off again.
And I remember my dad one time standing there and just telling me,
you got to stop.
You can't,
you can't eat.
I'm not going to let you sit here and kill yourself trying to ride this horse.
And you know,
of course
back then I didn't,
I didn't have a silly thing like a riding helmet or even a saddle.
I just,
I just had this desire to ride this horse and if it was going to kill me,
it was gonna happen.
And so I did.
I just kept after it and finally wore the poor horse down and he,
he gave up and he ended up being,
you know,
the by my side for,
for many years.
And so that,
that gave me this whole different level of freedom.
I wasn't constrained to my feet anymore.
I could go out and get just miles and miles away from it all.
And you know,
home wasn't,
it wasn't a comforting spot for me to be.
So I was much more comfortable being out in the mountains by myself with my
horse.
And some people might have an issue with this.
But by the time I was 12 I was carrying a 30 30 rifle on in a scabbard on my
saddle and I had a little Ruker 22 that I carried with me,
you know,
one or the other.
Usually when I was out riding because my parents felt like I was safer with a
gun than without a gun,
even though I was 12 years old,
I had grown up around guns and was comfortable with them.
And
since I would head out in the mountains and I think the,
the only rule I had was that I had to be back by dark.
And you know,
when you're on a horse and you leave first thing in the morning,
you can cover a lot of ground.
And if something had ever happened to me,
I,
I don't know how anyone would have even found me.
So I was,
I had to be responsible and self reliant to make sure that I was this safe as I
could be out there.
And I give my parents a ton of credit for allowing me that freedom.
They had a daughter who had this passion to be doing what I was doing and it was
dangerous and they let me do it.
And that is a large part of what built me into who I am today.
And so,
okay.
That,
you know,
that's something that I also try to do for my own kids as much as I can,
I'm,
I'm pretty cautious with them,
but I still try to always allow them a lot of freedom.
I remember one time I was,
I think I was 15 I was riding a way from home a little ways and I was down in
this creek bottom and I heard this commotion down there,
this like barking and noise.
And I thought there were neighborhood dogs who would chase deer.
And I thought that the dogs had a deer down down in the creek bottom.
And that was what,
you know what through my went through my head and I ran my horse down through
the brush into this creek bottom thinking I was going to scare the dogs off this
deer and I came out of the brush literally from me to you like five feet away
from this mountain lion.
It was just in full snarling crouch attack mode and it was squared off with,
I didn't,
I didn't know this when I was riding,
but one of my dogs had followed me and I hadn't seen it and it was down in this
creek bottom with this mountain lion and they were face to face just snarling
and crouched down at each other.
And I,
I came out of the bushes right on top of them.
And
you know,
I didn't feel any fear at all.
I just reacted and I just knew I had to get a little space between myself and
the lion and I spun my horse around and got up the hill just a little ways and
then stopped to watch the situation.
And the
dog was as big Wolf Chow Cross.
It was a big dog.
But she,
she got scared and she cut and ran.
She decided she'd had enough and she turned and to run from this cat.
And the second she turned to run,
the cat had her,
it just throw an arm over back,
reached under bid her throat and she just went limp.
And then the cat just picked her up and carried her away.
Yeah.
That's cause you're not supposed to turn your back on the ais.
Don't ever,
even when you've kind of wrote away,
I was Kinda like,
I am.
The reason I did that is because the cat was distracted,
right.
I wasn't the threat to the cat.
I was a side thing.
The threat was this dog.
And thank goodness my horse was just a rock and didn't dump me right in front of
this cat because had that happened,
there's no doubt in my mind that I would have been attacked.
Um,
but you know,
things like that.
That was,
that was my life.
Things like that happened and I was young and I had to be able to deal with
those situations.
How old were you at that point?
15 and there's all,
there's also this really,
really strong dichotomy here is that you're out in the wilderness on horseback
pack and heat,
you know,
confronting mountain lions.
And even with all that,
you didn't confront this
abuser and,
and that's another,
you know,
sign an indication to people of how hard it is psychologically for someone
that's as strong as you were as a teenager that's out there on your own.
Like I said,
riding around the mountains with a pistol and a rifle ready to,
you know,
get after it.
And yet this by this point,
kind of an old man is still has this level of control over you in your own home.
Yeah.
That's just,
um,
it and,
and I would say then
at this point maybe to fill that hole or to release some of that tension,
you start going down a path.
Yeah.
That's not a good path for you to be going down in life.
So when I was also 15,
I,
um,
met someone that lived a few miles away from us,
who was a,
I think he was in his thirties.
He was an Indian guy and he rode around the mountains on his horse as well.
And it was,
um,
yeah,
I did,
I developed a relationship with him and you know,
it was,
he was not the kind of person that you would want your 15 year old to be dating.
But to me he was,
it was just this romantic thing and it was this escape.
It was,
it was something different.
And with someone that paid attention to me in a time when I was really
struggling with,
um,
my home life and who I was,
I think the,
the molestation abuse stuff got harder for me as a teenager,
as I,
even though it wasn't actively happening anymore really physically,
it was messing with my mind a lot more because I understood it better.
And so I started dating this guy who,
um,
you know,
was
a distraction to me from that.
And you know,
in the way 15 year olds,
well,
I just became madly in love with him
and
you know,
you can make your own conclusions about a 30 something year old man dating a 15
year old.
Um,
I certainly feel a lot different about it now than I did then.
He Wa he told me that he wanted to marry me.
Like it was,
it was very serious in my mind.
And then one morning I was riding away from home down this dirt road and I
remember a neighbor rancher pulled up alongside me and asked me if I'd heard
what happened.
And he told me that this man that I was in love with had been shot and killed.
What was the,
what was the genesis of him being shot and killed?
It was,
like I said,
he wasn't,
he wasn't the most upstanding person and it had to do with marijuana and guns
and it,
it was just a mess.
And it was tragic.
Yeah,
he wasn't a drug addict,
but he led a life,
um,
of,
well,
I'll just say it,
he would steal people's marijuana plants from them and sell them and
that got him into trouble.
Um,
and I look back now on
the road that that relationship could have taken me down.
And while it was this horribly tragic event for me at the time that sent me into
an even deeper tailspin
now as an adult the way I am,
I'm almost thankful that it happened because I think that had that not happened,
who knows where my life would have gone.
And so what,
you know,
there's,
there's first of all,
I can see how 15 year old iris who's dealing with this stuff at home and meets
this guy that's,
you know,
31 and 31 year old is,
I don't care if he's a total idiot,
he can manipulate the hell out of a 15 year old all day long.
Yeah.
Eh,
but,
but regardless,
you're ended up your,
and it's just a super vulnerable situation because of your mindset and you end
up here,
you know,
in this relationship with this guy,
now he gets murdered and you go,
it's,
you,
you end up just going even worse at the time.
Yeah.
That was,
uh,
that was a hard thing for my 15 year old brain to process.
And shortly thereafter,
my parents separated,
not in an amiable fashion.
My sister went off to college so I was especially on my own because she was my
rock and I just really went into a cycle of depression and misery.
And um,
by the time I was 16,
I was dating a 32 year old cop,
which again,
you know,
I have very different feelings now on what a 32 year old cop is doing,
dating a 16 year old.
But
he was this safety zone for me in a big way.
He was this,
you know,
strong,
brave person who wasn't going to let anything bad happen to me.
And
I really latched on to that when I was just trying to find something in life to
hold onto.
And that ended up being a long on and off again relationship,
which definitely was not healthy for me.
And then at that point in time I started self mutilating.
I started cutting and burning myself.
Um,
I was definitely very depressed
and it was not something that I knew how to communicate to anyone.
I just was sucked into misery and self pity really.
And when you start hurting yourself,
is that
at moment?
Is it just so much anger and frustration that it somehow feels good to feel that
pain and we're inflict pain on yourself,
or is it more of a,
hey,
everyone,
look here,
I'm doing this to myself.
Maybe you should pay some attention to me and help me.
Or is it a little bit of both or is there something that I don't know and
understand?
I would say it's definitely both.
It's definitely,
it's a funny thing and it's hard to understand.
It's sort of an addictive behavior
and you know,
I've read about it some and they say there's chemicals released in your brain
and stuff when you feel physical pain that makes the emotional,
that Dole's emotional pain and things like that.
But it also,
for me,
I will absolutely say that.
Yeah,
I think it was,
it was a cry for help.
It was like
somebody realize what you know.
And as all teenagers do,
you think that you're some rare,
exotic creature that's no one else has ever experienced anything you've gone
through and nothing anyone says to you.
Yeah.
Matters because they don't know what they're talking about.
But
for me a lot,
if it was,
was it a cry for attention to,
to have someone and I got it.
The thing is is I got the attention,
um,
the,
the cop that I was dating told my parents that I was doing this and people kind
of freaked out and everybody thought that there was really something the matter
with me and I was really depressed and I wouldn't,
even though I was getting the attention and people were actually asking me like,
what's going on?
What's,
why are you doing this?
I wouldn't say,
I would not tell anybody.
I just was shut off.
And it's like I wanted the attention,
but then I still wouldn't say what.
And maybe part of it is that I didn't even know.
But I think what we talked about before of the not wanting to make a scene,
I was not going to make a scene this at this point,
my abuser was pretty old,
but he was still alive and he was still in our lives.
He still,
you know,
all the time and people were asking me,
what are you doing?
Why are you doing this?
And I was not going to say
going back to your writing.
Yeah.
By that time I was already damaged by so many years of abuse,
heartbreak and death,
painful and destructive relationships.
My parents were divorced in angry.
My sister had moved away.
I was in a spiritual,
oh,
I was in a spiral of self destruction in self pity.
I had taken a cutting and burning myself.
Scars that I still carry to this day to remind me of the way my life could have
continued
and that's what you just talked about and then at this point you're 17 or 18
years old and your abuser,
who you just said it was now an old guy,
he dies.
Then I'm going to continue.
I'm not sure exactly when I woke up,
when I shut off the Self Pity Fountain and realized that I was strong and
indestructable
somewhere in my early twenties my twenties was a slow rebuilding of my life the
way I wanted it.
Okay.
I traveled,
wandered,
worked as a horse wrangler around the west,
had relationships with men who were kind and decent,
got married,
got divorced,
made friends,
built up a reserve of strength and found myself little by little.
So I,
you know,
one of the reasons that you're sitting here today,
one of the reasons that I know you is that despite all that darkness that you
got sucked into,
okay,
you somehow in some way at some point realized that you were going in the wrong
direction and you,
and you turned around and started to,
and I know we,
I know we've talked about it before,
it wasn't like you woke up one day and said,
today I'm going to change my life.
You,
you transitioned,
you transformed over a period of time.
You can't put like,
you know,
you're not going to put a day on it.
You didn't have a Eureka moment,
but you slowly started seeing yourself from a different perspective and
realizing that the path you were on wasn't a good one.
Okay.
So as soon as I graduated high school,
I left to start working on ranches.
I went to Montana and I remember
clearly I was
18 I guess,
and I was working on a ranch in Montana and someone had left laying around this
dusty old copy of Dh Lawrence Book of poetry.
And I read this little poem and it just stuck with me and I'll read it here.
It's,
I never saw a wild thing,
sorry for itself.
A small bird will drop frozen dead from without ever having felt sorry for
itself.
Yeah.
And I read those words and they just,
they just hit me in the right place.
And I'm not saying that that in particular is what really started to make a
change.
But,
um,
I read some more things and you know,
I was growing older and I was thinking about things differently and my abuser
had died and that was probably the biggest weight that I've ever felt lifted off
of me because now what I realized is even if I did choose to tell someone it
wasn't going to cause the kind of scene that it would have before.
And I still didn't really choose to tell anyone.
But that in itself,
not having him actually be present was,
it was a big thing for me and I realized that I had just been damaging myself
and I'd really been hurting people in my life.
My,
my parents,
my sister,
they were just confused.
They didn't understand why I was where,
why I was doing what I was doing to myself.
And I realized that I was just in this,
I was being selfish and self centered and just feeling sorry for myself
and I stopped.
I just gained a little bit of perspective and made myself stop
that that perspective piece is so important and what's crazy to know?
We all have seen and everyone's seen people that are in the downward spiral.
They're just caught in the downward spiral.
Whether it's a relationship,
whether it's booze,
whether it's drugs,
whether it's behavior,
you can see it and when you're on the outside of it,
it's so obvious and you want to grab that person.
And I'm sure everyone,
I have literally grabbed my friends that I've seen in that downward spiral and
shaking them and saying,
get out.
Come out,
come here.
All you have to do is come over here,
step over here with me,
and look back and see what,
what situation you're getting.
You're in and you're the direction you're heading.
Hm.
And unfortunately you can't pull them out.
You can't pull their head out and let them look back at themselves.
They have to step out.
They have to come to that recognition themselves.
And that's one of the hardest things as a friend or as a family member to watch
that person.
It's like watching a train wreck and you know,
all you could do,
you know,
you could press the brakes,
you,
you realize how easy it would be.
Just a hay,
press the brakes,
press the brake,
stop.
Yeah.
And yet we can't,
we can't do it.
We can't help people.
Can you,
you have to help yourself.
And,
and so,
I mean obviously that poem,
you know,
seeing that was a form of you starting to take a look at it,
starting to take a look at yourself from a different perspective.
Maybe your abuser dying helped you start to look at that from a different
perspective.
Yup.
In La.
It was,
it was a long,
slow process for me though.
It didn't just happen overnight.
I mean I,
I think I'm the made a very conscious decision not to hurt myself anymore,
but you have to teach yourself how to think and feel and that takes time to
teach yourself to have the right kind of thoughts and feelings about things.
And
one thing that I wanted to say while I'm here talking about this is that just
because I'm sitting here saying that I did this,
that I s I woke up and stopped,
doesn't mean that everyone who's experienced something like this should just get
over it.
Um,
if you have listeners,
if you have a,
a girlfriend or a wife or a sister or someone who has been through something
like this,
or maybe after listening to this show will confess to you that they've been
through something like this.
Maybe they've never told you before
and,
and maybe they'll tell you something that doesn't even seem like that big of a
deal.
Maybe it's not years and years of abuse or
violence.
Maybe it is something that you know,
happen to them when they were young and it's a sucky situation,
but it's not,
it's not horrible.
It's a horrific,
but she still feels file lated and it's this personal process that you have to
go through and and friends and family and people that know someone is struggling
with this.
Definitely need to support you in every way they can.
But you also don't become a crutch
just because someone has gone through something like this,
doesn't give them the right to drag everyone else down with them into the,
into their pit of depression and misery.
So you support the best you can without enabling
the bad behavior because that's really what it is.
It's behavior.
There's
people who've gone through much more horrific things than anything I have ever
been through.
They'd have come out fine and it's just getting your mind in the right place and
taking control of your,
your thoughts.
And I know,
you know you have a obviously experience being being married to a military
member.
And I would say along the lines of what you just said is that people aren't
going to handle things differently.
Then you can have two guys that were on the same exact combat deployment and did
you know pretty much the same things and they're just going to have to deal with
it in a different way.
And maybe one guy gets over it pretty quick or maybe one guy barely even reacts
to it.
Maybe one guy,
it really hurts them and it takes them some time.
And it sounds like it's the same thing with,
with what you're saying,
we have to be
open to,
hey,
this may take some time and it may take a different course and at the exact,
again to mirror what you just said,
there's,
there's guys that just because they had some rough combat that doesn't give them
the right to number one,
dragged them,
drag themselves down the wrong path,
a number to drag their family and their friends down the wrong path.
And,
and I think definitely,
you know,
saying,
hey look,
I don't claim to understand what you've been through,
but I do know this.
Your behavior is not going to get help.
It right the,
the,
the bottle isn't going to help it.
The self abuse isn't going to help it.
The skipping work isn't going to help it.
So I think those are,
those are,
those are fairly similar.
Again,
I don't,
I'm not trying to say that at the same thing.
I'm just saying that there's,
that dealing with them has a lot of similarities.
Both guys that have been in combat trauma and people that have suffered this
type of abuse.
It seems like there's some similarities in the way that,
that there's varied ways that they can handle it.
There always has to be accountability for your own actions.
No matter what you've been through.
You can't just say,
I've been through something horrible so I can act like this.
Well,
you know,
case in point before we pressed record today,
you and I were talking about,
you know,
colonel reader who came on the show and who was a pow and it was amazing.
And you just think that guy,
you know,
just has been through,
he's been through hell.
And then he sits there during the podcast and says the same thing that you just
said,
which is,
look,
I had a rough,
but there's plenty of guys that had it way worse than me.
And,
and you know,
I think,
I don't,
I can't think of anything worse than a two foot tall bamboo cage in the middle
of the,
of the jungle with rats eating my wounds with my feet shackled into a bamboo
shackle.
You know,
that is just,
that's just unbelievable.
And to your point,
he comes on and says,
you know,
number one,
other people have had it rougher than me and number two,
I'm happy for it.
I've got it,
let's move forward.
So it really wasn't until my kids were born that,
I mean,
this was,
this was in my mind all the time.
I probably,
I would say into my mid twenties this is how prevalent it was.
I probably thought about the abuse at least once every single day.
It was always in my mind
and eventually I learned that I didn't need to waste my thoughts on that and
learn to spend less time thinking about it.
But it really wasn't until my kids were born,
I think.
And my daughter was five years old.
She was just this little girl,
this little girl,
and she was the same age that I was when I was already dealing with abuse.
Okay.
And that just made me burn with rage.
And I realized that I felt that I had an obligation to speak about this.
Did it happens to so many kids,
it's so prevalent in not,
you know,
girls,
but also boys.
It's not just girls.
This is how it happens in higher number to girls.
But it happens to both.
And
I felt like what I had been through and what I had,
you know,
I think I've come around and am a pretty well adjusted person now and that I had
an obligation to talk about this because it's something that doesn't get talked
about.
It gets swept under the rug and even people who have happened to get treated
like there's something wrong with them and theirs and they're embarrassed and
they don't want to talk about it and it's time for that to stop.
It's time for us to start talking about it.
And I'm,
I feel like I'm resilient.
I grew up with this really close proximity to nature and I've seen animals
suffer
horrific wounds that should kill them.
They don't have doctors,
they don't have medicine,
but they've got fire in their hearts and they don't feel sorry for themselves
and they survive.
And I credit a lot of my resiliency to my upbringing in nature and observation
of nature and how it's cruel and it's beautiful and creatures survive in the
most difficult and challenging service situations and they flourish.
And if they can do that,
so can I.
That's awesome.
That is just awesome,
man.
You know,
you kind of um,
went right to talking about your kids,
right?
To talking about your daughter,
you,
uh,
you know,
as you got out of that
bad time of your life,
you ended up meeting your,
your husband,
my friend,
and my note here is that do you meeting your husband was the best thing that
ever happened to him.
And,
and now,
and that's another reason why I w you know,
I really wanted to bring you on and have you share some of your experiences.
Obviously the be the abuse and your,
your survival and your attitude about all that,
but bringing also that strength to,
and you know,
people have always asked if I would bring my wife on and you know,
my wife,
yeah,
she's wonderful,
she's wonderful.
She's not coming on the pocket.
It's not her deal.
But you know,
people always want to know because there's a lot of young military families out
there and you know,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna say this right now.
I'm going to talk about military families and in the background,
I just want everyone to think,
first of all,
that also applies to,
you know,
cops and first responders and firefighters.
Maybe not to this in fact,
not to the same degree,
but also just normal,
you know,
hardworking Americans,
men and women who,
you know,
you've got someone that's working hard and gone a lot and dedicating a lot to
their job.
So that applies across the board.
But that being said,
you know,
you're a military wife.
Um,
my wife's a military wife and you,
you ended up in this situation.
Well you,
you met your current husband who's a,
you know,
like I said,
a good friend of mine and,
and we,
I was on my,
for my very first deployment ever back in the day,
had to fit that one in was he was on deployment as well and I think it was his
second deployment and you know,
we met and hit it off immediately.
He kind of grew up,
he grew up in California.
I grew up on the east coast,
but we grew up with a similar kind of background.
And that we were both kind of into hardcore music and metal and punk rock and we
were just into the same kind of stuff.
And we recognize that immediately about each other.
And so we became friends back then and with them we spent many years at
different and,
but we,
uh,
we ended up being together at seal team three.
He was in different task unit than me.
But anyways,
you got a guy,
you ended up being married to a great guy,
but who's a military guy deploying all the time.
You didn't come from a military background,
you didn't have military in your life.
What was that like?
How was it like being welcomed into the military family and the harsh realities
of a,
being married to a military member during a time of war?
Um,
yeah,
I,
I
definitely not from a military family,
I don't,
I barely knew what a navy seal was.
Um,
I wasn't impressed particularly with it
the fact that he was a navy seal.
MMM.
I think that I'm
fairly well suited to the lifestyle because I'm pretty independent and I'm
okay.
I don't tend to be someone who frats a lot over what might happen.
I know that he loves his job and he's well trained as he can possibly be to do
the job that he does.
And so you know,
that's really,
that's really all there is for me.
And you know,
of course there's moments where you feel a little bit sorry for yourself and
think,
gosh,
what if something happens?
What if he comes home without his legs or with half his face trapping old or
something.
But you know,
I don't anymore.
That stuff doesn't get into my head much and so I don't,
I just don't really worry about it.
You don't want to,
one of the,
you talk about being independent and I know obviously you're independent person,
you could get a lot by herself and,
and my wife's the same way,
very independent in terms of her day to day.
She doesn't,
she doesn't need me to actually do anything for her.
But I,
I wrote down a note just to talk about another level of independence and that's
emotional independence,
which I think is very important.
I think it's something that,
you know,
spouses need to find for each other because I think there's spouses that become
emotionally dependent on each other.
And that works in a day to day relationship if you're seeing each other all the
time.
But if your husband or your wife goes on deployment and leaves you for six
months to 14 months to 18 months,
if you're in a long deployment cycle,
you are not going to have that emotional shoulder to lean on.
It's not going to be there.
And so you have to learn how to be emotionally independent.
Now what's scary about this is that obviously if you get so much emotional
independence that you're no longer,
you could lose connection,
right?
Yeah.
And so that's what you have to watch out for.
And I think what you see with,
especially with younger married couples,
the emotional independence from one person leads up to leads to some kind of
emotional dependence on some of their person that they meet.
Next thing you know,
we have a bad situation.
So I think that emotional independence is something if you talk about with each
other and you said,
you know,
my wife was one of the best things about my wife is I w I wouldn't even talk to
my wife,
you know,
just not,
I wouldn't send her an email.
It'd be a week,
two weeks,
three weeks,
no email,
nothing.
Because I'm over doing my job and,
and she wouldn't think to herself,
oh,
he's not talking and send me an email.
Why aren't you emailing me,
send me know,
like,
Hey,
he's busy.
You know,
she wasn't dependent on me for her emotions.
So I think that's another important piece that you need to talk about with your
spouse if you're in a military situation.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
my husband's pretty good actually about staying in touch with me and
communication on deployments,
but it's not because of a emotionally being dependent on each other.
That's just the way he is.
He values my opinion on things a lot and we talk about things and um,
you know,
so,
so we do communicate quite a bit,
but I,
yeah,
I completely know what you mean about the,
and as,
as being a wife sitting at home with your husband gone.
Like you can't just sit there and pine over them being gone and wait for them to
come home.
You have to have your own life.
You have to
carry on while they're gone and that's the best way you can support them.
I think if you're,
you know,
making them feel bad for not calling you every opportunity you get.
And then laying a guilt trip on them about,
you know,
the fact that they're not giving you enough attention and stuff when they've got
you.
Yeah.
You,
you can't do that.
You've got to,
you've got to just take charge of your own life and,
and do that while they're away.
Now when they're away,
obviously that's some things you deal with them there a way and then you have
other things that you have to deal with when they come back home.
Especially during a,
during a hard deployment.
Now I know a lot of civilians listen to this show as well.
And it's important to recognize that there's different types of deployments and
even during the same time period,
exact same deployment cycle with two groups of people or a hundred groups of
people,
there'll be some people that are in an area or in an area of operational.
And we'll have a mission that will allow them to completely coast and,
and,
and enjoy themselves and have plenty of free time.
And,
and that can happen.
And then the other end of the spectrum is you can go on deployment and you can
think,
you can end up in total violence and chaos and mayhem.
And I just thought of this,
my first deployment to Iraq,
you know,
we did a lot of operations.
It was cool,
it was fun,
they were really good operations.
And when I got back,
when I was there,
I was thinking,
man,
I wish I would've brought my guitar because you know,
I had some time,
you know,
I'd be like,
maybe I could have probably played guitar for you know,
half hour day,
maybe 45 minutes to be for a couple of the guys would have brought their guitar,
we could add some little jam sessions.
Right.
And we were working a lot.
You don't,
our op tempo was high.
We were working,
we were probably,
you know,
we're doing probably a mission every one,
two or three days we were out.
So my next appointment I said to myself,
cool,
you don't bring a guitar,
you know,
with time,
get work on the work,
on the rifts.
Sure.
Go back in this deployment was to Ramadi and I think Lafe Lafe and I played
guitar so much time we played,
we played the tall one time when there was like three days left in deployment,
we broke out a guitar is good.
And there was another task unit there now and we were turning over.
But that shows you the difference.
And we,
we literally did not have any time to do any of that.
And obviously the,
the pressure of combat on my second deployment to Iraq was a thousand times more
intense.
And I know that your husband has done multiple deployments as well and they
varied in stress level and they varied in amount of combat and amount of direct
combat and his leadership,
uh,
situation.
But I know that,
you know,
not too long ago he went on deployment that was definitely high stress and they
saw a lot of hard combat and when he came home from that,
you know,
what was that,
what was that like?
What did you notice and what do you think other people should look for?
So
the very first night he was home from that deployment,
I woke up in the middle of the night and he was standing over the bed holding a
gun.
And that sort of shocked me a little bit and made me realize that I was dealing
with something a little bit different.
I talked to him on deployment and over the course of the deployment I could hear
his voice changing.
I could tell that he was,
he was changing.
It was,
it was strenuous than there was a lot of,
um,
engagement.
And when he came back,
he just,
you know,
when he woke up in the middle of the night,
his immediate response,
he just heard a noise that dogs barked or something and he just jumped for a
weapon.
He just startled
easily.
And that was his reaction.
Um,
he had a definitely a shorter temper,
little things that he shouldn't have been getting mad about.
We're setting him off,
you know,
just,
just dumb stuff.
Somebody would say something or do something and he would get so mad about it
and it was like,
you know,
take it down a notch.
He started,
um,
you know,
I don't want to make it sound like he was doing this in a terrible way,
but he definitely started some self medicating with alcohol.
He was slate relying on sleeping pills to get to sleep.
He has never been much of a drinker.
I'm not a drinker at all.
And so when I noticed him drinking more than he normally would every single
night,
uh,
you know,
that immediately was a red flag to me.
And then the sleeping pills,
you know,
this,
um,
ambien is powerful stuff and can really be a bad,
a bad road to go down
and
your guys definitely get on that Ambien road and uh,
I've seen guys go down that road and it's just like all of a sudden they can't
sleep without ambien and it messes up your sleep cycle and everything else.
So yeah,
definitely.
And I,
I guess that there's times when people need it,
but I think,
I think guys in the military slip real really easily from a guy that needs it to
a guy that's just doing it because they're starting to rely upon it for sure.
And it's weird that you talk about,
I mean,
we just had,
you know,
Dave Burke,
who was an Anglico guy,
forward air controller on the ground with,
with my team,
did a lot of work with my task unit in Ramadi and you know,
he was,
he was in f 18 pilot.
He was,
you know,
top gun,
uh,
echo just thinks he was straight up Tom Cruise,
but he was on the ground with us and Ramadi for a hell of a deployment and saw a
lot of stuff and in some very intense direct combat and exactly what you just
said,
like couple of things,
you know,
he said when he,
what he was talking about when he got home and he'd gotten the car with his wife
and his mom,
he was in there for 10 minutes and they were having a normal conversation.
All of a sudden he yelled at him like his temper was just short.
So there's the temper,
the increased 10%.
That's one thing people definitely get.
And the other thing,
you know,
the startle response,
which was,
which Dave talked about as well,
was you know,
he heard a,
uh,
air gun for putting the,
putting the working on a car.
He was walking by a garage and somebody fired off an air gun and he grabbed his
wife and through word of ground,
right.
And he was like,
he said,
while he was doing,
he already realized to,
what am I doing?
But it was too late.
So those are things to watch out for.
And then what about,
what about the,
I know you talk about the sleep pattern.
Yeah.
He definitely wasn't sleeping.
Um,
normally.
And so,
you know,
I started to,
to see stuff and I was like,
this isn't,
this isn't a road that we want to go down.
And so I told him that I thought he really needed to go see a psych.
And Luckily in the seal teams there's good access to that.
And also,
fortunately my husband listens to me.
He,
he,
he values my opinion.
And if I say something is amiss,
then he believes that something is a mess.
And so he went and saw the psych and I think,
um,
doc parsley,
I think you've talked about him before,
helped,
helped him to get on to,
um,
just a healthier sleep cycle,
cut out all the,
the medication.
He doesn't take any medication at all anymore.
Never,
never any sleep pills or anything.
Started taking like some herbal supplements and stuff.
And,
um,
he takes some Alpha brain now
and,
uh,
and it didn't take long.
He,
you know,
he made a few appointments with the psych that definitely helped him to realize
that yeah,
he was,
wasn't acting normally because I don't think when these,
when you guys come back,
you don't,
you've already been used to war operating on the elevated level for a while and
you don't realize that you're not,
you're now home with your wife and your kids and you're still trying to operate
on that.
Yeah.
Level intensity boil a frog thing.
That's normal to you.
It's normal.
You don't sense it when you're overseas.
You just are getting ramped up and ramped up when you're staying in this
heightened state all the time and everything is intense all the time,
but you don't notice it.
And so when you come home,
you don't notice that it's,
it shouldn't be like that right now.
Yeah.
And that's where it's really important for the family spouses and stuff to,
you know,
keep an eye on these guys and hopefully channel them in a good direction when
they get home as opposed to,
uh,
you know,
I had,
I not stepped in and I mean my husband's,
he's,
he's been a sale for a long time.
He's,
he's been through a lot of stuff but um,
you know,
he,
he definitely could have gone down a road that wouldn't have been healthy for
him more
his career.
No doubt about that.
I just remembered this when I think it was either right after you met here,
met right after you moved down here.
I think I was talking to him cause I was talking about where you guys were
living,
you know,
out and you guys had proper,
you hadn't bought property yet,
but you will rented a big property and you had horses and everything.
And I said,
Oh man,
well you know what,
what made you move out of here?
You know,
this is,
this is awesome.
And he's like,
yeah,
my wife told me she wouldn't come down here unless I got her a property with
horses on it
and here we are.
It's like awesome.
That's killer.
Yeah.
And then you know,
you talked a little bit about your kids and how that,
yeah.
How that helped you,
but you in the meantime,
as you were having kids,
when you got down here,
you started straight up farming.
Yeah,
I mean I,
that was a condition to him having me was that I was not going to put my horses
in a stable and go see them once in a while.
Like they were going to come with me and we needed land for them to be horses,
wild horses like they were used to being and so couldn't be seen.
He made that happen.
He made it.
He did.
He made it happen and we got a great 18 acre piece of property and we've got
five fat horses now out in the field.
Every time I look out and I never farmed before I'd always been a horse wrangler
and
I started just growing a little garden.
I was like,
Oh,
I love this.
And I heard about a CSA program,
which is basically where you grow a,
like you grow a bunch of stuff and you sell a box of whatever your farm is
producing every week to people who pay,
you know,
they'll pay to get their box of fruits and vegetables.
And I was like,
oh I could do that.
I could get a few people and start to do that.
And so I did.
I started out with like 10 families that I'd do boxes four and realized that I
really liked it and it gave me a lot of focus when he was deployed.
It gave me a lot of something to really throw myself into and focus on.
She wasn't going to pick like knitting,
playing this and I'm going to run a farm.
I like that,
you know,
we,
we had kids kind of write it right around that same time.
And so that was,
that was a little challenging itself to be trying to like get this farm up and
going and being,
you know,
in the beginning you talked about me being like nine months pregnant out there
working and um,
yeah,
street,
that's what I did.
But it was awesome.
You know,
I loved it and I've,
I've managed to build up a pretty decent little business and um,
there's nothing that I find more rewarding in life than growing good food.
There's something about it that's,
and,
and for my husband to like,
I do most of the technical farm work.
He's more of my farm boy.
Maybe labor.
Yeah.
But
um,
it's very therapeutic for him.
I think when he comes back from deployments and stuff and he will,
he can just kind of let all that go by being in this natural surrounding with
physical labor to do every day.
You don't need,
I think you've talked about this before,
don't need sleeping pills.
When you work yourself hard all day long,
you're married to iris
and go to sleep at night.
I've set my boy out.
Their husband's on deployment.
I'd send my boy out there just to,
just to do slave labor out there now that after it let him learn about an honest
day's work.
Sleep outside.
It was legit.
It's um,
you know,
I eat one of the things you,
you had written and this is,
you know,
different topic,
a different,
the different article that you'd written and I'm just going to read a lit a
little okay.
A little chunk of it because I love it.
Here we go.
This is about,
you know,
being on the farm with your,
with your now,
uh,
this is when you just had your,
your one daughter.
Yeah.
Here we go.
My garden helper turns one year old this week.
I remember when life was simpler,
when I could work in the garden all day uninterrupted,
when I could sleep,
when I wanted and be out of the house by the early morning.
But I didn't laugh nearly as much.
My heart wasn't as large.
I was more selfish.
These days are slow.
This baby and I,
there are so many little breaks.
We take things,
we get distracted by things that must be learned.
I feel lucky to accomplish one or two small tasks in a day.
Now
that is enough though.
We manage.
There was nowhere she would rather be than in the garden.
Makes me happy to see her dirt street face.
Smile.
I've gotten past everything having to be clean.
Okay.
Let a child be a little wild.
Let her experience the taste of dirt,
the feel of leaves,
mud and water.
Let her grow in the garden like an artichoke,
rambunctious and beautiful.
She laughs out loud,
throwing her head back to point at the birds.
She squeals with delight when she gets a hold of the cat and crawls like Matt to
get out of the way of the sprinkler.
This is nothing that can be replaced by toys.
Nothing that can be learned from books or videos,
parks or playgrounds.
This is my sweet child.
Sweet has the honey suckle,
blossom,
dirt and doll.
Lots of good stuff.
Bringing those kids up on the,
on the farm.
Yeah,
and you know,
continuing down that and kind of bringing it up to to the present,
you wrapped up the article that you wrote about abuse and you kind of talked
about where you're at now and I'm going to,
I'm going to hit that.
The person that I am now,
I'm fairly proud of considering I carry very few scars from my past other than
the physical ones that are carved into my skin.
I am comfortable talking about abuse.
I can look at pictures of my abuser and feel very little.
I am married to a kind of courageous hero of a man.
I've built up a beautiful farm.
I've got two amazing young children who I will protect with my life,
which is really where this story begins.
The children
look around you.
Please look at your own children and other children that you see.
Look at your friends and relatives and watch their interactions closely.
We fear so many ridiculous things in life,
but we don't fear the most common dangers to children.
Nearly enough.
We like to think of child molesters is strangers,
not the people we know and let into our lives daily.
Stay vigilant.
Trust your gut instinct.
If something seems off,
remember even very young children can keep tremendous secrets.
This is uncomfortable,
okay?
But sometimes uncomfortable things need to be handled head on until they no
longer have the power.
That secrecy and silence gives them.
Thanks for listening.
Please share and keep the children safe.
And then,
and we,
you know we've talked through some of this but I kind of want to just you,
you kind of laid out and you've talked about it already,
you know just in what we've discussed so far.
But I think it's worth covering again from your perspective,
your thoughts on it,
on how to keep children safe and some of the things to watch out for and some of
the things to do.
Here we go.
I think the best answer is talk about uncomfortable topics early and often.
Don't just have the talk with kids,
talk to them on a regular basis about their bodies,
sex,
predators,
consent.
If they never hear you talk about it,
it's going to be harder for them to bring it up to you.
I know communication is difficult.
Many families remember it's not up to the kids to do it.
As an adult,
you have to initiate hard conversations regularly.
Don't ever assume your kid is too young for something to have happened to them.
It can literally happen in a few minutes with a friend or family member when you
are out of the room.
Ask them if they've ever been touched inappropriately and we're in a way that
made them feel uncomfortable.
Then ask them again and again a few days later,
bring it up.
Casualty the second time.
Hey,
I was thinking some more about that conversation we had the other day.
Give them time to process and decide if they can handle telling you.
Do not push kids to hug and kiss people if they are resistant to it.
Even family members,
this is a topic that they should be familiar discussing with you.
Everyone treats it like it's this dark secret that we can't talk about,
that makes kids feel like they can't talk about it.
Either.
Take every opportunity to bring it up in conversation,
a new story of Facebook posts,
a friend dealing with issues.
Talk about what's going on and why
we may think that we are doing our kids a favor by keeping this horrible stuff
from them.
But the statistics and the women who have spoken out here prove that most likely
your child or grandchild will have to deal with it alone.
If you aren't proactive,
if you have four female children or grandchildren or nieces,
chances are at least one has or will be molested.
Some kids just will not talk no matter what.
Be Observant.
And if anything ever seems slightly off,
follow your gut instinct.
If a child or teen tells you they haven't been touched her molested,
don't take their word for it.
Kids can be amazingly good at keeping secrets.
Okay.
And that's,
I think it's just a great list for people to think about,
to put,
to put into action.
And
really a good,
a great example to live by.
So that you can be aware of this stuff ever happens.
Yeah.
I want the subjects to be normalized a lot more than it is.
Um,
you know,
yeah,
it's a horrible thing to talk about and it's hard to talk to your kids about it,
but we have to make it more normal,
not only for kids,
but for the millions of adults that are out there who've been through it and
still don't talk about it.
When I first posted,
um,
what you've read,
I posted it on Facebook and I had a ton of people send me private messages
telling me
their own horrible stories.
People that I knew,
people that were friends of friends,
people that I didn't know at all.
And I was shocked by a few of the people that I knew who had horrible stories,
um,
kids that I went to high school with that I knew during the time that their
abuse was also going on.
Told me some things and
everyone just deals with it and doesn't feel like they can talk about it.
And that's,
it's,
it's not right.
And so I hope that it,
my coming on here and,
and bringing this to light and being the person that I am and saying,
Hey,
let's have an honest conversation about this will help someone else.
Even if one or two other people
decide that they can change their life for the better because they hear someone
addressing this honestly,
or one or two other people look at their
kids and the interaction that their neighbor or their friend or their
GRANDPA,
uncle somebody has with their kids and realizes that there's something not quite
right.
Okay.
Then everything that I've been through is worth it because I will have used my
experiences to help someone else.
Yeah.
Well definitely appreciate that.
And I know we focused a lot on that today and again,
I,
you know,
you as a,
as a military wife,
I also wanted to take up
a moment to recognize all those military wives out there that hold the line.
Okay.
While their husbands are,
as you know,
deployed overseas in harm's way.
And
I wrote something for one of my daughters and at this 0.1 of my daughters was
quite frankly not treating my wife with the kind of respect that my wife
deserves.
You know,
it was typical teenager stuff or roll the eyes,
a flipping comment.
Basically young adolescent girl with young adolescent attitude.
What you talked about earlier.
No,
no one can tell me anything.
I know everything.
And in her mind,
you know,
my wife was just some lady that did the laundry.
He got the groceries and cook dinner
and that's how she treated her.
And
so I wrote this for my daughter,
but I,
I wanted to read it for everyone and I,
and I want to
dedicated not just my wife,
but to all the military wives out there holding the line on the home front.
So this is what I wrote to my daughter.
Your mom.
I wanted you to know a little bit about your mom.
Your mom was a champion horse rider.
She wrote cross country races,
show jumping,
and she did fox hunting.
She cared for horses every day,
clean them,
train them,
and took care of them.
She won many victories.
Your mom worked since she was little starting in restaurants first peeling
potatoes than busing tables than cleaning,
than waitressing to make money.
Okay.
Your mom went to an extremely good college.
Her parents didn't pay for it.
She worked through college as a waitress to pay your own way.
Yeah.
When your mom got done with college,
she took the money.
She saved and backpacked around the world.
She went to Thailand,
Malaysia,
Hawaii,
Australia,
New Zealand,
and a bunch of other places.
While doing that,
she worked as a waitress and other odd jobs so she could make money and pay your
own way.
Okay.
When your mom got done traveling,
the economy was bad and she couldn't find a job,
so she went overseas and worked at an airline as a flight attendant,
which is a hard,
thankless job,
serving on grateful passengers on planes.
She didn't like it,
but she did it.
When I met your mom for the first time,
she was the most beautiful girl I had ever seen
and when I talked to her,
she was the nicest person I have ever met
and she was funny and Sassy and sweet,
and I knew immediately that I wanted to marry her.
So your mom picked up everything and left and came to be with me in America.
She moved into a tiny one bedroom apartment with me.
She was wonderful.
She was adventurous.
She surfed with me and she trained you Jitsu with me every day and worked out
with me every day.
She got her blue belt in Jujitsu.
She worked as an executive assistant in a real estate office and got her real
estate license.
We went skiing and hiked mountains and camped under the stars and the mountain
and we went dancing at night.
She was amazing.
I got orders to move to Virginia.
She instant week,
packed up everything we had and quit her job and moved across country.
When we got to Virginia,
she got a tough job working for an insurance company.
Of course I was in a seal platoon,
so I traveled all the time and was gone all the time and she never complained.
One day she told me she was pregnant.
That was you.
She was so happy
and then the day after you were born,
I left on deployment for seven months.
She did everything by yourself.
I was gone.
She never complained and she sent me a picture every day of you.
Yeah.
When I got home from deployment,
she was already back in shape and looked amazing.
The navy gave me orders back to California without a word.
Your mom packed away.
All of our stuff quit her job.
When we moved back to California,
I worked and went to school.
I never got up in the night to help take care of you.
It was always your mom.
Every time she changed every diaper,
made,
every meal,
dried,
every tier.
Read every good night book.
I worked,
went to school and trained Jujitsu.
She never complained one single time.
Soon she told me she was pregnant again.
That was your first sister when your first sister came.
Now.
Everything that your mom did for you,
she had to do for your sister too.
Every diaper,
every meal,
every tear,
every little book read.
I was working and going to school and training.
She walked you both and read to you and took you to parks and play groups and
dancing lessons and swimming lessons and craft fairs.
She did everything for you.
She didn't get to surf anymore or do Jujitsu anymore or work out or hike with me
anymore.
She devoted all that time to you.
Her kids who she cherished.
She never complained or wind or asked for anything.
Then she got pregnant again.
This time it was your brother?
Yeah.
She kept doing everything for you.
When she got her morning sickness,
throwing up dizzy and carrying around a baby in her belly.
She didn't complain ever.
When she was in the bathroom sick and throwing up,
she would apologize to you and you said you and your sister that you girls had
to see her like that.
Then the war started.
I went back to the seal teams.
I went to Iraq for six months.
I was working so much that I barely got time to write.
Your mom always wrote me.
She never complained about anything.
She did everything and by herself,
everything.
I was taking care of my seal platoon and she took care of you.
Three little kids.
She cleaned everything,
made every meal,
changed every diaper,
dried,
every tier,
took you to lessons and parks and doctor's appointments and read to you every
night and made your lunches and got groceries.
She did this all by herself.
No inlaws to help out,
no grandparents around,
just her alone.
When I came home,
things didn't get any better.
I just started getting ready to go back to Iraq again.
She didn't complain.
Some guys had to worry about their families.
Their wives would complain and cry and file for divorce and fight over the kids.
I never worried about that at all.
Your mom took care of everything and never made me have to worry about you kids
or her or anything else.
My last deployment to Iraq,
I was gone almost seven months.
I left your mom alone again with you.
Three kids.
Okay.
Some of my men were wounded and killed.
Your mom went to the hospital to visit the wounded men and went to the funerals
of my friends.
Your mom knew at any time it could be me that was wounded or killed,
but she never complained.
She cried with the moms.
If my friends,
she gave support where she could,
but she never asked me to stop or come home or leave early or even be safe.
Never.
She never asked me to give anything to her.
She knew I had men to take care of.
She told me not to worry about her or all you kids.
She only told me to do my best at my job and take care of my friends on the
battlefield.
Most seals get divorced almost 90%
there is too much pressure and separation and distance and too many challenges
and many women can't take it,
so they leave.
Your mom never wavered.
She never had an issue or a complaint.
No matter what happened or when I came home or when I left or what I did,
she supported
me always and she took care of you kids every day.
Every night.
Every moment.
Yeah.
Every need you had was her responsibility.
She never asked for thanks or appreciation and when it was her birthday or our
anniversary,
she would tell me not to get her anything so we could save money.
When I got home from my last deployment to Iraq,
your mom got pregnant again.
That was your youngest sister and she did it all again.
Morning sickness,
diaper diapers,
sleepless nights,
Puke in the bed,
pee on the floor,
chicken pox,
lice,
tears,
scrapes,
bumps,
bruises,
teacher conferences,
school lunches,
everything.
She never complained about it.
I was still working,
preparing men for war at traveling all the time and she continued to take care
of you kids so I could do my job.
Your mom has stuck with me through hell.
It has been hard.
Your mom has been married to this hardheaded frogman for 17 years.
She's been through multiple war time deployments.
She has helped me when I was sick or injured.
And she has done the same for you.
She has done it because she is strong and determined and she loves our family
more than anything in the world.
Your mom is an incredible person and amazing woman.
And I wore shipper.
She is everything I ever wanted.
Yeah.
So
when you get the chance,
you should tell your mom that you love her,
that you know how much she has done for you and for our family and that you
appreciate everything that she has done for us and for you.
Hi.
Hope you grow up and have some of the same qualities that she possesses.
Strength,
honor,
intelligence,
dignity,
selflessness,
respect,
determination,
had kindness.
That's your mom.
And I hope you realize how blessed you are to have her.
And that's the note that I wrote to
daughter.
And
you know,
there's some people
that say a woman can do anything that a man can do.
But I don't know if that's true or not.
But I can tell you this,
I don't know of too many men
that can do what my wife has done.
And what thousands of other military wives have done.
Right.
And I want to recognize
how blessed we are as a nation
to have these women out there holding the line on the home front
a job.
And yes,
it is a job that is underrecognized and overlook all the time.
Yeah,
Iris,
like my own wife.
I think you are a
stellar example of this.
Thank you.
No,
thank you for what you've done for your family,
but also what you have done for our country.
It's supporting your husband and your family
and
thank you
and obviously thank you for coming on here today to to teach all of us about a
subject that we all need to know more about.
Not just abuse but also determination and on top of that determination to
overcome what you experienced in your life,
but the determination to keep a family together
and
protect the protectors.
Well,
it's been a,
it's been an incredible honor to be here and,
and thank you guys for stepping out of box a little bit with me and getting this
out there and,
and talking about some of this stuff and I love,
you know,
what you wrote to your daughter and your wife is still stunningly beautiful and
very kind.
She is.
Yeah.
Is indeed.
And it's,
you know,
having you on the podcast was a no brainer.
I,
I probably waited three or four months to broach the subject with your husband.
I was waiting for the right moment and he said something to me about it and I
was like,
you know what,
hey,
if he,
if she ever just happens to want to come on let me know.
And I,
and,
and he answered me in 30 seconds and it wasn't his answer.
Said I just talked her,
she's good to go.
I was like,
yes.
So it's been great having you on the podcast.
Thank you guys.
Well speaking of the podcast,
sure.
Echo journals,
I mean if somebody wanted to support this podcast,
is there any way they can do that?
Yeah,
there is actually kind of the,
you know,
we talk about these heavy things is kind of the,
the time to decompress a little bit.
Right.
A little bit.
We can talk about supporting the podcast.
That's a good way to decompress I think.
So most of the time.
Let's talk about supporting ourselves.
No,
no,
because actually a lot of it like being like a strong military wife and all this
stuff,
even even just a normal,
no,
this,
I'm going to say this too.
I didn't say this.
There's military husbands as well.
Yeah,
it definitely,
and,
and they're,
they're doing all that stuff that I talked about.
I was talking about wives because that's what I deal with.
I dealt with my wife,
you know,
and,
and you're a military wife,
but guys that are out there holding down the fort and also there's guys that are
married to police officers.
There was the,
I know that that gets flipped sometimes and,
and respect,
respect,
the equally challenging,
uh,
for,
for anybody that's,
that's holding down the fort at home.
So
the concept,
yes.
You know,
a lot of times,
especially when you're dealing with kids and the responsibility is on me or
whatever.
And I,
I mentioned this before,
where it's easy to fall into that kind of mindset where you're making it about
yourself.
Now you know,
where you have kids and it's like,
Hey,
I got a change.
I changed the diaper last time.
You know,
but if you notice you're talking about yourself,
not the diaper got to get changed regardless,
but you're like focusing on the fact that you had to do it,
you know,
kind of thing.
So not that you're wrong,
but you chose to make it about yourself.
So the less you make it about yourself and more about the mission,
the family that the,
whatever it is that you're doing,
the stronger you're going to have the,
um,
like the capability to be,
you know,
you can like solve the problems,
accomplish the mission.
Anyway.
So that being said,
let's make it about ourselves for a second,
by supporting ourselves.
So this is kind of a flip.
You know he's switching.
You know how like in the,
in the airplane they say support yourself.
Before you support the kit,
you got to put the box,
you got a basket,
the oxygen,
you know what I mean?
Because if you support yourself you have more capability of supporting others
to story.
Right.
That's why
the stronger he was all excited.
He's got iris over here.
She's a green sheet is like blowing me off
cause she knows.
She mentioned Alpha Alpha Brag,
all these things and I started taking more Alpha brain.
By the way,
I think I noticed that today.
You are sharp or crisp with the thoughts.
Yeah.
I felt like I was a bit distracted.
Not necessarily here but just in life.
You know,
I couldn't like focus on the thing that I needed to make videos or whatnot.
I've been making videos.
I,
I've noticed that.
Yeah,
that's good.
We like that.
Anyway,
if you're working out,
you want supplementation,
you want some support in the workout,
which actually I'm down for.
No,
I wasn't a supplement person before,
as I said before.
But now I am because there's supplements like Krill oil,
you know,
strong bones.
Strong bone.
Yeah.
Is that for like bones to,
it might be,
but I just,
I don't know.
My bones seemed strong.
I don't break them very often,
but my joints want help.
So I take it for the,
I take it for the joints.
Yeah.
Cause he figure cause usually when like your tendon detached,
like you know how it ripped my bicep or whatever.
It's the tendon ripping off the boat.
Yeah.
So you figured joints strong.
Maybe that's,
you know,
the strong boom is that's the part of your homework.
Do some research,
get back to me anyway.
If you want the good supplements,
Krill oil for your joints.
That's a big one in my opinion.
In [inaudible] opinion.
My opinion,
this is opinion man.
Essential.
So we,
whether you're working out or whether you're actually working on the farm.
Yes.
To krill oil,
all the pin.
Um,
that's a good one.
but as far as supplements go,
you know,
you get the good ones when you get on at once anyway.
If you want 10% off on it.com/jocko my joints,
here's the thing,
like all,
all bus out krill oil whenever it's applicable in my mind.
And people be with who,
you're always talking about Krill oil.
No,
but I feel like it's kind of always on my mind because
you know,
like,
okay,
I'm talking to Greg the other day.
I don't,
I don't think Greg's on the Krill oils.
We're talking,
it's after where he should be.
Yeah,
we're talking,
we talking for a while about stuff or whatever.
It's like,
oh,
it's time to go.
We get up Greg.
He goes,
oh,
like that.
Oh No,
I understand that.
He didn't have to make that noise,
but he making that noise is an indicator indicator.
Somebody ordered that man Krill oil.
Exactly.
That's exactly what I thought.
I didn't say nothing,
but that's what I thought.
That's kind of the place.
Maybe.
Maybe it was like it was too fresh.
So let's just make this just for this whole advertisements.
For Greg Train.
Gretchen gets it on the Krill oil and you won't,
and it's less about making that kind of noise or not making the noise.
It's the feeling that compelled him to make the noise.
That's the important part of Greg train wanted 10% off.
What would you do then?
I'm trying to help this along.
If he chose to get 10% on it.com/jocko the slash Jocko,
that's the part that gets,
it gives you the 10% off on all your stuff.
Even if you like protein powders and whatnot,
which,
which is good too by the way.
I look on there,
see what,
what you know,
cause it depends on your lifestyle.
You see what I'm saying?
Anyway.
Does you get it?
You get my drift.
Okay.
So we do,
that's a good way to support yourself and the podcast and ultimately everyone
around you actually everyone in the world yeah.
In the world will be more supportive ultimately.
Yeah.
Like the butterfly effect,
you know,
like us talking,
it'll affect China later anyway.
Amazon click through.
That's a good way to support too,
by the way.
Um,
so what that does is,
you know,
before you do your shopping,
you click through the website,
Jocko,
podcast.com the tab on the top banner on the bottom thing is with the banner.
Oh,
I'm only saying this because people that keep me up about it and they'll say,
hey,
I don't see the banner.
Your banner is not there on the website.
If you have an ad blocker,
which is a smart thing to have,
by the way,
just generally speaking,
if you have an ad blocker,
it'll block certain things and sometimes that banner will fall within the
confines of things that the ad blocker blocks.
Yeah.
See what I'm saying?
I,
you know what?
We could also change our whole attitude here and make the full focus of the
podcast and the website and everything that we're doing to get people to get
into the give us money.
Yeah.
We're not going to do that.
Right.
So like now that I'm thinking and talking to you guys about it,
I'm like,
man,
I should really go change that.
But when I go home,
I want to go,
you know,
other places I'm thinking about getting after it.
I'm thinking about,
I'm making videos,
what have you.
So you know,
I get reminded of it.
So,
and maybe that's a good thing.
Maybe that's a bad thing,
but nonetheless,
those are the facts as of right now.
But it doesn't matter because there's a tab on the top.
Like I said,
click on that one.
If you want to support it takes three seconds.
Small action.
And that support that,
that everyone's been given big reaction
and somehow this supports China.
You were saying eight Gen ultimately.
Yes.
It's the butterfly effect.
Look into it,
sir.
It's look it up.
It's real.
Yeah,
it's real.
Uh,
you can subscribe to the podcast and this is on any podcasting,
providing platform.
Google play,
iTunes of course,
stitcher.
Okay.
Yeah,
you can write a review too,
which I've done some,
I've read some live reviews on here.
Yeah.
Of Jocko white tea.
But I might do that with the podcasts because there's some really good,
good on there too.
I was actually thinking of doing a Facebook live and reading the comments on a
picture that Joe Rogan posted of me because there are some funny comments.
Yes.
Pro comedians out there listening to Joe Rogan.
So they want to make fun of my head.
Yeah.
But they're worth reading.
You know,
there was,
um,
remember that video that we made actually clung to,
I don't even might've been before the first podcast even maybe after,
I don't know.
Anyway,
we made it and it was about martial arts training and you're,
you know,
what's the best martial arts and self,
all this stuff.
Right.
So it,
I revisited that and this was a while ago.
There's like millions of,
there's over a million views on that.
Right.
So with views come comments,
right.
So he's like that though.
Typically.
Yeah.
You know,
it's usually not very productive to spend much time in the comments section on
Youtube,
but
lot of views,
a lot of comments.
Let's see what the P,
and it's not like people who've necessarily follow Jocko podcast.
That's the thing is random.
So you get a cool little like variety of of people in there,
so yeah,
there's some interesting ones in there.
I didn't quote any or nothing or save any,
but I'm just saying generally speaking,
it's interesting nonetheless back to subscribing to the podcast.
Youtube.
Yeah.
We have a youtube channel.
If you like the video version of this podcast a
sometimes like people know what you look like.
Yeah,
and I there,
but a smaller percentage of people know what I look like.
Yeah,
and I'm not encouraging you to watch the video to see what I look.
I'm not saying that echo doesn't look like what it sounds like.
You definitely look different than you sound.
Did you,
have you ever seen him before today?
I've seen pictures of you online and I was surprised when I did because you
sounded sort of,
well no,
I'm not going to say what she sounded like the sound,
the way you look for now.
We'll assume that that's how he does something like that.
One Guy said a mixed white and Latino,
not hipster like skate,
not skater,
I don't know.
Something.
Anyway,
they got real specific,
which is good.
Which is cool.
Yeah,
I dig it well.
Yeah.
I guess it's because you have a weird background being up a Hawaiian.
What are you half black,
half white guy?
Yeah.
I mean not to split hairs,
but there's some native American in their native both sides.
But see none of that has anything to do with the way you talk,
the way you target list,
the way you talk.
Yeah.
I have something to do with the way you,
yeah,
yeah it does.
I don't know why I said that,
but yeah,
I mean yeah.
Growing up on Kauai and then living here and then,
I don't know.
Okay.
You all the time.
All this stuff just jumbled me up,
you know.
Anyway,
back to the,
you want to see what he looks like.
You could check them.
You're interested in something like that.
If that interests you,
subscribing to the youtube channel might facilitate.
Cause conversely I look like what?
You got to think.
I'm going to look at exactly what I look like.
Yeah,
exactly.
True.
Exactly true.
So,
yeah,
the youtube also also,
my looks aside,
what we do now is,
and we've been doing this for a little bit,
is uh,
take a little excerpts of the podcast,
little lessons and we'll put them on there as well so you can share them.
You know,
it's easier than sharing the whole podcast and having people receive it,
you know,
cause he can't just listen to two and a half hours on a whim,
you know?
No.
But three minutes to kind of schedule that.
You got to schedule it.
Yes,
exactly right.
Three minutes.
So no schedule required.
Let's schedule press play right now.
Yeah,
yeah.
Lesson learned.
Boom.
Yeah.
Individualistic,
improved.
Good to go.
Yep.
Rock and roll.
Yes,
exactly.
So that's really the goal there.
And you know,
I gotta be like,
people have said,
you know,
I always say this,
well people have been asking me,
it's one person,
knock in my case.
People have been saying like,
that's good to have those ones because some people,
they don't listen to the podcasts like the first day,
you know,
they're like how you said they kind of got a schedule.
Even somebody,
even we've got a lot of commuters and people listen to this car.
Yeah.
But you know,
half an hour commute.
It takes you a few days to hear the whole podcast,
but there might've been a little nugget.
You need it for work that Monday.
Yeah.
Some people they'll say that helped me that day.
Like the college one that you talk about,
like how to approach college.
Yeah.
Legit.
Anyway.
You wish you had that when you approached college.
I wish I had all of this really and I,
but when I approached anything in life really.
But yes,
the college yet.
So yeah,
subscribe to the Youtube Man.
That's,
that's a good one.
That's a good way to support.
And that's another way to support yourself in a way.
It kind of indirectly.
Um,
and then if you wear tee shirts at any point and you want to represent a little
bit,
but that's uncle t shirts,
you know,
I think you've,
I think they're pretty cool approved.
They're approved,
quite literally all approved stars,
a new tee shirt out,
which you are wearing at this time.
I like it.
It's real complex.
Yeah.
It's black and it says get after it on it.
Amen.
Technically it's a charcoal Heather,
but fashion guy,
man,
you know it is what it is and there's usually more to them than kind of meets
the eye.
We call that layers
philosophical sense.
Um,
but yeah,
you know,
if you want to support that way,
that's a good way,
you know,
and you get a shirt that you can wear.
Very wearable.
That's the thing.
They're not that cheap ballpark.
Give away shirts.
They're like good,
very wearable.
Multiple occasions people say it's my favorite shirt to wear because of the fit.
People are telling you that people every single day.
All Day.
Yeah.
I'm telling you
women's on their women's stuff on their shirts,
patches,
rash guards.
I'm going to put out a new rash guard here is pretty soon.
Not that that's like it's supposed to get everyone fired up or nothing like
that.
Yeah,
it was good.
The hoodies are on there as well.
And you know,
if you like any of this stuff I'd say,
I'd say just look at it.
If you choose to support,
if you feel like supporting you feel like representing,
go ahead and get something that's a good way to support.
Yup.
And also
this one I'm on.
What I'm about to tell you here could very well border on essential.
Now it's like one of those things where,
okay,
so psychological warfare we're going to talk about,
I'm gonna go into it.
So you know how like let's say you're getting after it,
IRS getting after it,
I'm getting after it.
I start taking krill oil.
Irs starts taking Krill.
Jocko is not taking Krill oil.
Maybe someone else comes in,
they start getting after it,
they start to,
meanwhile you're not taking the Krill oil.
We're kind of ahead of you.
You know,
you see his ll soft.
Conceptually that's a big deal.
So psychological warfare,
what that does is case psychological warfare isn't album with tracks with Jocko
in there.
Put simply Jocko on there helping you through any moments of weakness that you
may have on your getting after it.
Journey.
Waking up early in the morning,
every day,
sleeping on the Diet,
procrastinating all these things yet big deal.
So if you think about just the procrastination one.
Yeah,
procrastination is one of those things.
It's a massive problem with people,
right?
People all over the world have a massive problem with procrastination.
Think of how easy it is to,
to overcome that.
It's the easiest thing.
It's the easiest thing to overcome.
Psychological warfare.
Yeah.
You just do just to go do what you're procrastinating and it's already what you
want.
I have,
it's not like you have to work,
get over procrastination.
You just just crush it.
You just go back the other day or last week,
whatever,
when I said like,
you got to switch it to manual and procrastination.
You just got to switch it to manual for like literally two seconds,
one,
two,
boom,
and then you do it.
Cause once you're starting,
right?
Yeah,
you're doing it.
You are no longer a procrastinator,
but I didn't initially see battled a win and what a,
what a battle that so many people face and lose and lose.
It's,
yeah.
It's one of those psychological things that you kind of got to declare war on,
and in that case,
you're engaging in psychological warfare.
Nonetheless,
this is a good way to,
so,
okay,
so back to my point about when everyone starts getting after it and you're not,
so I,
I don't want to feel that.
Like everyone's like Google.
I do.
Horford cause you can't listen to it and like,
Hey,
I don't want to wake up.
I want to press the snooze.
You can't listen to wake up,
you know,
one of the first checks or whatever.
You can't listen to that.
And then not,
we got,
you can't,
you won't be able to face yourself.
It's like one of those things they said like that strong.
So let's say everyone's doing that.
You're kind of left behind.
If you're not,
that's how I feel.
Like if I'm not doing it,
you know,
I'll do it.
Even if I feel like working out,
I'll still listen to it.
Give you a little kick,
a little kick.
Anyway,
psychological warfare,
Jocko Willink.
Word.
I was looking at an audio book the other day.
It's still number one by the way,
man on spoken word.
Everyone's getting on it.
Yeah,
man,
it's been that way since it came out.
That show everyone that you're telling to get after it,
they're getting after it.
That's part of my 0.8 they're like,
you got to do it also on clicking,
when you're clicking through Amazon,
you can also get Jocko white tea and here's the bottom line.
You know,
we all need to deadlift more.
Yes.
Alright,
sure.
Don't play around.
If you order your Jocko white tea,
you're going to boost your dead lift two approximately 8,000 pounds.
And I was thinking about this the other day.
You think 8,000 lbs is heavy.
It's in another,
you know,
unit of measurement is four tons.
Yeah,
Bro.
I think that's good,
man.
That's really good.
You want to do that way.
The warrior kid,
by the way,
it's not even preorder anymore because it comes out May 2nd,
right?
So it's coming out soon.
Boom.
Order it now and save a child.
Smash a bully,
save yourself smashed.
Pullups that's the,
it's your role.
Messenger for,
I was at the [inaudible] game yesterday,
yesterday.
And so there's a playground there and the kids are just kind of running a amuck,
you know,
and a lot of times this parents in there and there's this one kid he was,
he was big.
Oh.
And he had that look on his face.
I'm not saying he was a bully,
but you know,
walk around and he was like grabbing another cat enough.
It was his brother.
I Dunno if he was bullying him or helping him or whatever.
But you could tell like all the little kids fit,
cause you know there's some people there like there's a line for this little
thing that the kids get on.
It's like a minute,
it's not a merry go round.
It's the thing you sit in.
And so some kids are real assertive,
there'll be like,
oh it's my turn cutting the line,
not even realizing there's a line in whatever.
And then there's some kids,
they'll stand in line and they'll just sort of let people write this cut.
And then there's some kids who were like,
oh wait.
And they'll explain there's a line,
you know,
so you can see the different levels for people out there.
Yes.
So like something like this that's going to turn you into,
you know,
the person who's,
it's kind of like the leader
can turn you into a leader.
It sounds like Kenny Williamson might've been out there.
Kenny Williams is a bully.
Now,
interestingly,
I'm doing the,
there was a lot of,
I ask questions.
Who should read the audio for this?
Right.
Cause it,
if I was thinking I would just read the whole thing.
Then some people said,
hey,
you know,
Jocko,
you're not a kid and it's a kid's voice.
It's in the first person of a kid's voice.
Kids named mark.
So I couldn't read the kids part.
I decided,
you know what,
I'm not gonna read the whole book.
I'm not going to eat the kid's park.
But there's a character in there named Uncle Jake.
Sure.
Now Uncle Jake,
he was a seal.
Sure.
And he's going to come and help out.
And I,
I decided maybe I could read uncle Jake parts.
So I did.
Seems like.
And then we got a kid reading the kids part and I think you all find out who
that is.
And I think there'll be some layers behind that,
that party.
So yeah,
weigh the war.
Your kid,
you can order that now you can also get discipline equals freedom field manual
is coming out.
What's a field manual?
It's something that you allows you to take information and put it into action.
That's what the,
that's a discipline equals freedom field and was going to do,
it comes out October 17th might seem like that's a long ways away,
but so did May 2nd but this thing's coming out around the corner.
So the
field manual,
it's basically this podcast in a book.
You can't bring this podcast into the field with you.
I guess you can put it on your headphones.
I guess.
Maybe you can,
but sometimes you need visual cues.
Yeah.
So that's what it is.
The thoughts,
the things from the podcast.
But then it also has very specific additional information like workouts,
sleep strategies,
martial arts,
you know,
everything that's cool in the world.
It's all about luck,
you know?
So you can do that extreme ownership.
You can,
you know,
by the way,
why is extreme ownership is still one of the top books on Amazon and iTunes and
audible a year and a half after it came out.
Why is that?
Is it because of the big advertising campaign that we did?
No,
it's not because that it's purely because of word of mouth.
So everyone that's listening this right now that's buying it for other people
and spreading the word,
it's because of you.
That's awesome.
Appreciate it.
Extreme ownership.
Amazon.
Why is it not out on paperback yet?
Do you want to know why?
You know why?
Yeah,
it's not out on paperback because people ask me why has it been on paperback?
It's not an a paper back yet because books come out on paper back when they
aren't selling the hardcover anymore.
They release a cheaper version here.
Does in paperback now it's only 995 they haven't done that with our book yet.
Why?
People still want the hardcover.
It's still selling.
And the reason for that is because,
because it works because people get a lot out of it.
So if you don't have extreme ownership or if someone that you know
doesn't have extreme ownership,
just like they don't have killer,
I'll tell Greg train he needs krill oil.
Tell your tell your subordinate leader or your superior leader or members of
your team tell him,
hey look man,
I'm going to get you a little something here for it to help you out shooting
ownership and if you need
some more extreme ownership at your team,
company contact or whatever your your your you can contact our company
Ashkelon on front,
Leif Babin,
myself,
Dave Burke,
JP Denelle,
leadership and management consultants.
Do you want to bring us on board,
contact us info@echelonfront.com and also along the same vein,
if you don't know,
we have the muster coming up.
Number zero zero two in New York City at the Marriott Grand Marquis,
come get your leadership on.
You will become a better leader.
Period.
Life's going to be there.
Jp is going to be there.
Dave Burke is going to be there.
Want me to be their echo?
Charles is going to be there and a ton of people that listen to this podcast and
that we've worked with are going to be there.
Come and get it.
We'll see you there.
And until we do get the monster,
if you want to communicate with us you can find us cruising on the interwebs.
Now.
First of all,
we're on Twitter,
we're on Instagram.
You can also
find us on the Facebook.
You can find us there.
So Iris,
yes,
for Facebook.
Where you at?
Uh,
you can follow my farm on Primeval.
It's primeval gardens on Facebook and Instagram.
And then I'm on Twitter at only IRS Gardner
and I just told Iris to sign up for that this morning.
Not a Twitter,
but I will,
I will.
That's what you Ferris did to me too.
Yeah,
it's just sign up for Twitter.
No big deal.
And then a bunch of people were like asking me questions.
Yeah,
what the cool thing is what the day,
that's what's makes it cool because you can communicate with all these different
people and they can give you good information.
They can tell you what books to read and they can tell you what speeches to
listened to and they can tell you what youtube he is checkout and they can tell
you what you did.
Just get this awesome.
It's a great way of communicating with a bunch of people.
So you don't have to quit or Twitter.
I don't actually cause you know like can the day the sent messages with pigeons,
right?
Yeah.
You know,
they send the message.
So it's like when you send someone a message,
it's called the tweet.
Yeah.
But what does that have to do it don't tweet though.
They,
I don't know.
The detailed
birds tweeting messages.
That's what Twitter is
this related to birds?
Sure.
And Messaging Pigeons.
Exactly right.
Which now we have an animal expert in the room.
They don't
know they need to change the name of Twitter.
Well,
yeah.
Well No,
they have to change the name of tweet tweeting the act of tweeting to,
to that noisy.
Yeah.
Tweeting.
But that's what it is.
A little less interesting.
Wheat.
Yes.
You got anything else for us today?
Yeah.
You said You,
um,
your dad made gold bars.
Yeah,
I'll beat with the bar because you know,
you get,
cause they could,
maybe that's a second
free.
It stuck with me the little like,
like,
like crop and gold kind of crumbs,
right?
First.
Yeah.
You get just little fragments.
So x pieces when you crush up or if you're like going in those streams and
creeks,
you'll come out with golden nuggets,
which are naturally forming larger,
but when you're crushing it or you just get little tiny flecks of gold and then
you refine it down into a bar.
And I,
I don't remember.
I think,
you know,
they do them in a,
a few ounces to whatever size is,
makes sense to sell.
You're the word gold bar.
You're thinking,
you know,
like on the movie you're watching it.
Yeah.
Not like a,
not like a 10 pound crack or whatever it is,
but yeah,
smaller bars.
That's pretty cool.
Is that your final question?
Awesome.
Iris,
anything else you want to close out with?
Gosh,
no,
just thanks for,
thanks for doing this.
Thanks for getting me on here.
And,
um,
love listening to the show.
I,
I
okay
listened to it when I'm out working,
getting after it.
I need to get after it shirt.
You know,
I always like going over your house cause you and you and your husband both want
to expand the conversation and port stuff out to me and ask about this science.
It's always awesome to have you guys listening,
but thank you.
Anything else?
I think we're good.
Well
obviously thank you for coming on.
Seriously.
I think it's awesome.
I think it's courageous and brave and really helpful for a lot of people.
I hope so.
And thank you for that.
Thank you for giving us a warning
that
that evil can hide anywhere
right under our noses and slink around and trying to corrupt those that are
closest to us.
So thanks for telling us
to hug our children,
to hold our children and to watch our children closely.
And also thank you for reminding us once again that in the end,
evil cannot win if we decide that we will not let it,
because if we confront the darkness,
if we stand up with courage and we look upward
toward the sky,
the light will shine on our faces and wash out the darkness and bring us warmth
and hope
it happiness.
And thank you for showing us once again that even with the evil,
okay,
and the darkness of the world,
and even with the scars that they can leave even still,
even with all that
this life,
his is sweet,
has the honey suckle,
blossom
dirt and all.
So until next time,
this is iris and Deco and Jocko
out.